todos los asistentes están en modo de sólo escucha bien yo al final pues os
iré respondiendo me ponía es que no se oye nada pero parece que ya se debe oír
no a ver se oye no se oye porque me dice abierto que sí soy bien soy escribirlo
está comenzando todos los asistentes están en modo de sólo escucha escribo se
oye se oye ya que no tiene que el disco el país pues venga a ver invitación es
público a ver que tenía por aquí esto es para luego esto aquí y aquí tengo
el el discor y aquí tengo las preguntas se me oye distorsionado dice raúl pues
no sé no sé si será a ver si alguien más dice por ahí algo si se me oye bien o mal se
me debería de ver bien pero claro vayan bien vayan bien a ver preguntitas que había bastante
bastante cosa por el discor antes de abordar los sistemas intradieros bien comentaba alejandro
las voy a ir poniendo las voy a ir poniendo esto se hace más grande aquí de alejandro lo que
preguntaba así para evaluar un sistema tendencial que lógicamente funciona mejor en activos
potenciales comentaba en el curso que miraba el adx y el atr el adx utilizas la media histórica
no te parece este dato un poco sesgado y decía también que si es decir es decir que estás
operando en temporalidad diaria y el activo tiene 15 años de historia realmente tiene
utilidad la media una vez más útil evaluar si está en tendencia por la media del adx del último
año o dos años es que la media cuando hay tanto histórico ya apenas cambia y si el activo cambia
es forma de actuar tú no lo vas a estar leyendo sí bueno el ejercicio que hice que entiendo que
te refieres a él en la teoría donde usaba el atr y el adx usaba una media histórica de todos
los datos que tiene cargado el adx o el atr que no deja de ser un análisis comparativo comparativo
entre distintos activos es un poco su utilidad por eso la tierra era en el porcentaje y porque
en puntos pues no te da esa capacidad comparativa y el adx en sí pues ya tiene un valor que ya ya
está normalizado por lo tanto ya es comparable entre distintos activos eso es un poco su lectura lo
que comentas no es que esté no es que esté mal el adx recordar que al final pretende decir si hay o
no tendencia no tanto si es a un lado o a otra aunque el adx se descompone en dos en el de más
y el de menos que eso sí que cada uno por su lado pues en teoría tiene bueno en teoría no es que es
en teoría es que como todos los indicadores pretenden una cosa pero no siempre no siempre
lo consiguen perfectamente pero pero sí el principio es su objetivo y como digo se compone
del de más y el de menos bueno entonces es un poco a nivel a nivel comparativo hay otras maneras el
más el más ortodoxo del más ortodoxo es usar el coeficiente de cursos ya os lo comenté pero no
es tan fácil de calcular y al final esto puede ser una manera de hacerlo es verdad que en gráficos
aunque yo hice el análisis ahí no es que esté mal hacerlo no es que esté mal hacerlo pero a
cuanto más y tiene el gráfico es el más largo plazo más fáciles en contar tendencia vale esto
donde se ve más más más claros en el mercado de acciones ahí es es es absolutamente el lugar
perfecto para mostrarlo tú tienes mira esto en el gráfico podemos decir cotidiano que tengo de
seguir los futuros se ve se ve bastante bien se ve bastante bien tú en un intra día de acciones la
mayoría de días lógicamente no siempre pues el mercado es bastante bien revertir de hecho en
acciones pues lo que mejor va es la revelación pero sobre todo en intradía más sobre todo en
intradía diario también también pero ya se puede encontrar tendencia vale ya se puede encontrar
tendencia y a medida que vamos subiendo el plazo de acuerdo es decir tú tú ves aquí este gráfico
en un horizonte diario que estamos viendo un gráfico bastante desarrollado y de hecho aquí
estamos cubriendo pues un período de barras bastante bastante importante y como vemos tenemos
una lateralidad bastante aunque es alcista tenemos una cierta lateralidad podemos decir
visual visual es verdad que el hecho de que hayan tantos indicadores que ahora quito pues
se agrava este esta sensación no pero a medida quitas indicadores parece más altista no pero
ya me entendéis ya me entendéis y a medida que yo amplío mucho amplío mucho prácticamente ya
solo me parece que hay una tendencia alcista y esto como mejor se ve pues lo que te digo si tú
puedes un gráfico mensual un gráfico mensual pues si es esto es alcista más no poder esto es
alcista más no poder aquí se parece súper alcista vale o sea súper tendencial por lo que estoy
hablando alcista lógicamente hablando de tendencial pero en este caso pues alcista no en
cambio te digo a la que vamos a la entrada es todo se vuelve mucho más lateral prácticamente
es un gap un gap y lateral de acuerdo es un gap y lateral vale y esto es así es así donde es más
pasa un poco en todos los tipos activos pero el equity quizás el que es más paradigmático entonces
a nivel de a nivel de mirar tendencialidad ya digo en diario y ya no te digo en semanal pues casi
todos los activos o son tendenciales o en cualquier caso son más tendenciales que en una que en una
temporalidad más corta en las temporalidades interdiarias realmente no es fácil de contar
tendencia en términos generales no es fácil de contar tendencia y ahí normalmente suele ir mejor
el min reverting o en el mejor de los casos el volatilidad y breakout vale porque al final por
la tibia breakout recordar que la teoría lo comentamos no deja de ser un tipo de una especie
de tendencial donde lo lo limitamos con objetivos y demás por lo tanto ya pierde su su clara
tendencialidad pero digamos que busca entrar en entrar o sea en tratar de común tendencia no
entra en rupturas pero ahí volatilidad breakouts que no sale que que su vida como digo es tendencial
es un mecanismo de entrada podemos decir que es muy parecido al de un tendencial pero claro cambian
mucho las salidas y eso pues totalmente cambia el comportamiento del sistema entonces estos análisis
que hice en la teoría pues estaban básicamente en gráficos no recuerdo si eran diarios o a lo
mejor hasta eran en semanal quizá entonces pues ahí sí que todo es un poco más tendencial pero
ahí yo te digo es más bien un tema comparativo Alejandro más bien comparativo comparar un activo
con otro el hecho de si mirar en ese hay mucha o poca tendencia vale veremos también cuando evaluamos
evaluamos no tengo claro exacto si será en tres clases o en cinco vale pero pero haremos una clase
donde usaremos un buscador de señales digamos que haremos varias varios setups que nos permiten
buscar mecanismos de entrada y que indirectamente también nos sirven para evaluar cómo de tendencial
es un activo ya lo he comentado algunas veces más bastante conocida y bastante fácil que
simplemente pues en una vela diaria comprar ante la ruptura del máximo del día anterior y cerrar
al cierre entonces esto es un indicador de la tendencia y lo mismo para la parte baja y eso
es un indicador de la tendencialidad del activo por ejemplo no es decir este tipo de cosas
realmente pueden servir para ver hasta qué punto un activo es tendencial vale ante las rupturas y
también nos sirve para eso vale entonces hay un poquito varias varias maneras el adx de lo que
dices tú del sesgo yo lo veo un poco más al revés es decir a medida que si tú reduces el
periodo es donde lo vas a sesgar si realmente es cierto vas a ver si en el último año dos años
pues ha sido un activo bastante tendencial pero en este ejercicio como te digo lo que mirábamos
tratábamos de ver era por comparación que características tenía ese activo con otros
comparado con otros vale era un poco la idea vale que más bueno luego aquí también había
comentario este de carlos de que un artículo sobre el algoritmo de posicionamiento con una
explicación una comparativa entre fixed fractional fixed ratio pues lo tenés que repasar porque la
verdad que tengo muchos apuntes sobre eso y cuando volvamos a repasar y tratemos en las prácticas
un poco esos temas que ya lo haremos podemos decir más bien de la mano del porfolio que ahora por
cierto quiero hacer un comentario respecto y luego luego lo haré y pues ahí lo trataremos más y
si un caso ya tenemos material carlos pero ahora mismo tengo es que tengo tengo bastantes pero bueno
repasaremos un caso de las teorías y dije de que entregaría algo de desceso o que o bueno
igual se refiere a los artículos que tengo hechos de mucho tiempo pero es que la verdad los que
si revistas no vale bueno ya lo ya lo apúdate que lo miramos lo miramos lo miramos mañana y dice
exactamente que es en la clase que se un monetario de 2 de minuto 40 a la despatrédict vale perdón
si lo has puesto en los puestos y vale vale vale sí sí sí vale vale la la pues ya ya lo ya lo ya
te lo te lo apunta apúntame lo alberto que lo que lo pongamos si lo ponemos en el disc or lo
podemos hay en el disc or de la el artículo que tengo de bueno que debo tener varios es patrín
de ejes de monetaria pero si ya los pondré ya los pondré y sirven ahí de apoyo también pensar que
dimos material aquí es decir que puse material ahora no me acuerdo que puse exactamente si puse
algo de eso pero no es está bien ponerlo es está bien ponerlo a no sé si añadimos de
ejes de monetaria algo no no me acuerdo no no había nada ahí vale pues añadiremos todos
esas esos artículos que comenta que carlos es que se monetaria que viene que viene vale jose
manuel jose manuel tenía ahí una lista bastante larga bastante larga de preguntas
vale él hablaba de la guía de configuración del server bueno la guía de configuración del
server la verdad que sinceramente aquí en la empresa tenemos dudas hasta qué punto es súper
útil eso pero bueno bien lo lo lo lo evaluaremos de cara sería un tema más de cara al final vale
más de cara de cara al final pero sí que sí que inicialmente queríamos hacer algo al respecto
vale pero pero en directo es complicado porque yo no me puedo conectar al server me entiendes no
me puedo conectar al server en directo es complejo no sé cómo hacerlo porque porque el porque ves
la ip entonces me lo revientas no lo puedo hacer en directo tengo que grabarlo y entonces hacerlo
al grabarlo lo puedo editar no y le puedo tapar la ip entonces es un poco la la la tema en directo
no es fácil entonces sí que teníamos decisión de hacerlo y de hecho un poco ya explicamos en
la teoría pero tenemos ese problema a ver cómo lo cómo lo podemos resolver vale ya le daremos
una vuelta el respecto a mesa estaría en algún mini tutorial con su uso para que no que casos
merece la pena no tiene alternativa entre eso multichars a ver es que es que jamón el caro es
que si ya intentó abrir el curso todo lo que puedo de verdad humanamente porque es verdad que es
para nosotros como ya he dicho es el curso y quiero tocarlo todo pero el todo en el sentido
estricto es literalmente imposible porque claro porque es que es imposible entonces haríamos un
curso de 70 mil horas esto es que fíjate que ya en las prácticas en la teoría nos pasamos mucho
y en la práctica nos vamos a pasar mucho más tengo cero dudas eso entonces al final
bueno en algún modo lo vamos a ver vale entonces como como lo vas a ver en el curso porque ese es
mi el motivo justamente por el que quiero ir usando distintas herramientas es ese vale que
vayáis viendo vosotros y que sin querer pues los vayas aprendiendo o viendo o que luego ya
enseñarte cómo buscar en su ayuda etcétera vale entonces msa en el curso lo verás en las pláticas
en algunas clases saldrá vale y entonces ahí pues podrás ya ver cómo va y verás cómo lo
monto yo etcétera etcétera entonces un poquito lo aprenderás msa al tener una que casos merece la
pena es muy baratito y además recordar que tenéis una oferta yo os lo recomiendo mucho os lo digo
de corazón por el precio que tiene da mucho no sé dónde lo puse la verdad pero pero le envió
un correo a ver si colaba y coló y nos ofreció un descuento que os puse el material igual no no sé
dónde la verdad lo puse alguien se acuerda donde lo puse primer día curso igual no material hay
preguntas habría que ponerlo otra vez porque donde sea pues también es verdad mira lo está aquí
esa materia lo que pasa que ha caído ha caído un poco porque ha habido añadido otra cosa añadí
aquí un documento de la forma genético del material que se ha quedado un poco un poco atrás
vale pero bueno recordar que aquí está la oferta de msa haciéndolas de descuento y yo sí lo
recomiendo vale porque para la gestión monetaria viene muy bien entonces lo mismo lo puede hacer
si lo puedes hacer en otros pero no es igual sabes es muy práctico msa que permite probar
muchos algoritmos que se monetarían de manera de manera rápida yo por el precio que tiene de verdad
que os lo recomiendo hay alguna forma de trasladar código de la meta trader no rápida no no hay no
no me consta que haya es una pregunta ya reiterada en muchos años y no me consta profundizar más
en porfolio maestro como usarlo para evaluación preliminar que es el porfolio selección de sistemas
bueno la verdad que lo que hemos visto en teoría y veremos en algún momento pero bueno ya iremos
viendo iremos viendo como iremos viendo y no que has visto la teoría claro la teoría se ha visto
un poco como va maestro y lo que sí que puedo hacer también también apuntamelo alberto porque
tengo por ahí una guía bastante buena de maestro y eso sí que podemos darlo porque maestro ha
cambiado entre 0 y 0,01 en los últimos años así que es una guía que es antigua pero que
está totalmente en vigor porque no ha cambiado nada maestro maestro ya te digo te aviso de
como él es un programa muy potente pero te vas a exasperar con él es exasperante porque es
tecnológicamente claro todo evoluciona compras un móvil este año y le da mil vueltas al de
bueno del año pasado ya no porque ya no avanzan tanto pero le hace tres de da mil vueltas vale
yo me lo cambié hace poco y estoy alucinando con lo que dura la batería pero una cosa increíble
un cambio lo demás nada es un poco mejor porque ya no cambia tanto pero ya digo la batería es
alucinante bueno pues maestro es el mismo hace diez años entiendes entonces claro hace diez años
pues bueno va iba tirando hace ya cinco decías bueno es un poco pesado ahora ya va pasando el
tiempo y te parece una cosa alucinante no evoluciona no mejora y se está quedando atrás que ya en sí
está pasando pero maestro es el líder de esto de acuerdo es el líder de esto porque no evoluciona
evolucionan me refiero a velocidad velocidad de procesamiento de este tipo de cosas entonces
tiene ese problema maestro vale sería bien tener ejemplos prácticos de cómo montar espérate que
esto casi que lo pongo aquí porque así lo podéis también ver exactamente lo puede saber bien es estas
preguntas de juan morelle decía que estaría bien tener ejemplos prácticos de cómo montar
una matiz en excel para elegir sistemas desco relacionados para diversificar yo casi estoy
seguro que esto lo hice pero lo haremos más aprovecho esta pregunta para creo que está por
aquí te tengo que contestar en privado es decir no es que no te contese privado porque
mensajes con eso privado pero pero pero como como ya he visto que estabas por aquí pues
serén te contesto te contesto vale primero gracias gracias por tus palabras y
comentaba también del tema de por solio que quizá pues le faltaba algún tema bueno lo bueno mira
quería hacer un comentario de esto porque lo mejor que tiene en mi opinión las prácticas
es que podéis interactuar y cuando me refiero a interactuar está bien influir también influir
entonces influís mucho porque en base a lo que vais preguntando lo que vais diciendo pues nosotros
sabe lógicamente recibimos ese feedback y adaptamos el contenido del curso porque no hay nadie más
interesado aparte de vosotros que nosotros en que quedeis satisfechos de acuerdo entonces al final
viene muy bien porque ya dio no sólo interactuar sino que influís el curso por supuesto que este
este rollo que estoy pegando ahora lo podrá oír a alguien de aquí dos años seguramente grabado
pero no podrá influir de acuerdo no podrá influir no podrá enviarme una email y decirme
esto y aquello para que yo lo tenga cuenta tienes y esto es una ventaja que tenéis que está bien
que uséis vale entonces está muy bien que los llegue a los comentarios porque pues los
tenemos en cuenta que los tenemos en cuenta ya digo que agradezco las amables palabras y
también agradezco las sugerencias respecto al contenido que va en esta línea lo que comentaba
el porfolio quería ver un poquito más tema de porfolio veremos más temas de porfolio pero
en porfolio de verdad y ya sé que hay mucha literatura eso lo voy a decir este porque no
voy dando saltos de un tema a otro de verdad que no os calentéis la cabeza lo que mejor funciona
y más robusto es equal weight vale no os hagáis bajas mentales lógicamente más optimizaciones en
el porfolio y por esto por aquello vale porque sí se pueden hacer 250 cosas se puede hacer
marcó bich y se puede hacer la frontera eficiente y no y se puede hacer el pino puente vale pero el
problema es si eso será robusto luego me entiendes entonces al final los sistemas en sí ya tratamos
que sean simples robustos y tal y luego a nivel de mezclarlos ya entiendo que haya duda si querías
vale como lo mezclo vale pues igual waited de verdad igual waited no os calentéis nos calentéis
en buscarle ahí las vueltas porque al final yo ya lo entiendo tú tienes un sistema que es muy
bueno porque hemos pasado igual nosotros por ello no tú tienes un sistema muy bueno y luego va
sacando otros y son una birria vale dices joder cómo lo voy a poner a igual esto no bueno si es así
si es birria muy bueno entienden claro es depende de lo que implique muy bueno si tú me estás
hablando muy bueno con 10 años operando en el mercado real vale parlemna que digamos en catalán
parlemna ahora si estamos hablando muy bueno a nivel de bactés o con dos meses operativas real
pues no es muy bueno de acuerdo es simplemente prometedor nada más muy bueno es en el mercado
entonces como si hablamos de situaciones más o menos comparables en cuanto a más o menos
prometedor pero uno lo ves más prometedor que el otro no te fíes porque el que es muy prometedor
de pronto en tan mala racha y resulta que llevas todo el peso y el que era una birria de pronto lo
peta tres meses seguidos y tú resulta que lo tenías ahí súper para súper bajo de peso y te
atragas entiendes sólo se ha pasado que se está hablando de la experiencia de errores que uno ha
cometido lógicamente porque para eso lleva 20 años y si alguien se piensa que en 20 años hemos
cometido pocos errores quiere decir que lleva poco tiempo en el tráil y porque tenemos muchísimos
errores lo bueno es intentar aprender de ellos y que no sean tampoco errores catastróficos de acuerdo
que sean errores pues asumibles entonces al final no es nada fácil tener claro
que mezcla de sistemas va a ir mejor por experiencia yo he llegado a este concurso y ya sé que no es
muy atractiva no es muy guay no que ya sé que gustaría una fórmula y tal que decir ostia esto
lo va a petar la cartera sí sí pues intentamos que eso se pueda dar con los sistemas de acuerdo
pero luego ya a nivel de mezclarlo no es fácil así que nos apoyamos de herramientas como ya habéis
visto maestro como ya habéis visto por folio trader como ya habéis visto y veréis también
más msa y también veréis un poco de cual analyzer vale entonces veremos todo este tipo de herramientas
que nos que nos ayudan a tomar una decisión vale pero ya digo que el equal weighted viene muy bien el
cual waited viene muy bien y no hay que perder mucho la cabeza ya sé que hay otros que defienden
otros pero también hay otros que defienden esto es bastante conocidos entre ellos entre ellos que
recuerda ahora mismo que espero no equivocarme pero estoy casi seguro que que bien debió recomienda
eso estoy casi seguro que perric afman recomienda eso y ahora no sé un que recomienda también
cual wey ten no me acuerdo ahora un que no lo sé puede ser no no sé tengo dudas tengo dudas no
tengo dudas pero me entendés quiero decir que no nos pensé es que es algo que todo el mundo
sabes hay autores que recomendar el cual wey ten y entre ellos estoy yo entonces porque por
lo que os digo porque es complicado garantizarse la mezcla entonces al final eso te garantiza
diversificación y riesgo cubierto me entiendes porque a lo mejor no es la mezcla que más dinero
va a ganar pero sí que es bastante probable que sea la que menos dolores de cabeza te va a dar
entonces como siempre hay que pensar en eso en caso de duda el equal weighted te te cubre muy bien
eso pero bueno cuando lleguemos ya discutiremos sobre esto aportaremos y veremos pros y contras
y veremos también que claro que se puede optimizar claro que yo puedo meter ahí una función fitness
optimizar el porfolio hecho lo he hecho y lo puedo hacer igual que viste ya por folio trader
que optimizo una variable pues puedo optimizar el management si quiero y en msa lo puedo hacer lo
veréis y lo hemos hecho el tema es si yo lo optimizo y lo que sale lo aplico yo lo optimizo
o sea que no quiere decir que no optimicemos recordar que optimizamos muchas veces para obtener
información no quiere decir que optimizo y aplico lo que sale al máximo vale pero sí que me sirve
para coger optimización y coger referencias para ver el optimizador que opina no que al final es el
final optimizador opina en base a los datos no que opina en esa mezcla ya ves que a veces escupe
algún sistema pues porque es una virgen de sistema por lo que sea no decir vale perfecto él lo escupe
pero yo normalmente intento que lo escupa menos entiendes porque porque sé que que es que es como
os digo que de pronto el que iba fatal con los datos antiguos porque está en una mala época de
pronto empezar bien el que va muy bien y hacer mal y así no entonces si depende de tu mezcla
resulta que te puede salir ahí te puede ir aún a un drábado muchísimo peor por culpa de eso no
por culpa de su cambio le cual waited pues cubre un poquito más eso vale perdonar este inciso para
el porfile pero que lo trabajaremos que lo trabajaremos y que como decía que había enviado
un correo sobre esto agradezco muchísimo de verdad los los comentarios y hacerlo libremente
porque ya digo podéis influir en el contenido del curso eso pues en mi opinión es una gran
ventaja no poder poder influir vale ejemplos se realizan investigación y puesta en marcha de
un sistema con code bueno como dicen aquellos me gusta que me hagas esta pregunta porque esto
está previsto esto ya estaba previsto supongo que lo dije en la teoría en algún momento pero
a lo mejor no no sé he hecho tantas cosas de la teoría pero sí sí lo tengo lo tengo previsto
o sea tengo tenemos varios sistemas sobre los que he hecho y una de las clases que tengo pensada
hacer es sobre eso de acuerdo sobre sobre los cortes tengo tantas cosas pensadas que yo creo
que haremos 78 horas de pero bueno vamos cuando tenemos un sistema de evaluación preliminar y
queremos ver qué entradas o salidas son las más óptimas se ven probando a mano varias hay alguna
manera sistemática de elegir cuál es probar y qué basarnos para tomar unas otras en evaluación
preliminar simplemente buscamos ver si el sistema es apto para seguir adelante no simplemente ya
recomiendo ya os comenté básicamente que gane dinero sí que se suele probar en casi todos los
casos incluso en la entrada y aunque el literaria cuesta más que vaya en distintos activos vale
pero es simplemente que es rentable que la y que el edge es es es explotable y tiene ventaja vale
hicimos una clase de formar le te recomiendo repasar la una o varias viendo un poco como
evaluamos si una ventaja pues tenía cierto tenía ventaja no tenía hecho es un poco la idea para
seguir adelante claro tú ahí que miramos es que no no no miramos mucho ahí no se trata de mirar
muchos ratios de verdad es simplemente que tú veas que la ventaja tiene potencial no no no no
di unas cantidades porque es que no hay unas cantidades ahí dices oye claro si tú sin
comisiones imagínate que no le has puesto comisiones tienes un profit factor de 1.5 en
ese momento sin haberlo trabajado por esa bueno 1.5 depende qué tipo de sistema estaría bien un
intradía o muchos trades podría estar bien pero pero se va en diario por ejemplo sería poco sería
poco también es también es que depende sólo evaluas la entrada estaría bien un sistema acabado
completo que ya esté parecido como lo base o igual a como lo base evaluaría al final sería justo
pero un sistema que sólo le evaluas a lo mejor la entrada estaría correcto vale entonces no hay
un dato inequívoco al final de evaluación preliminar no deja de ser una especie de prueba más rápida
que haces para no perder mucho perder mucho tiempo con cosas que ya no valen para nada y que se ve
rápido que no valen explico es decir es más bien un descarte que otra cosa entonces si tienes
dudas sigue para adelante acuerdo si tienes dudas sigue para adelante pero es para para descartar
rápido podemos decir no pasa que yo lo explique largo porque pues lógicamente la teoría lo explica
es largo pero pero muchas veces eso es un momento y además es una cosa continua que ya tiras con
esa y sigues con las siguientes es continuo no es continuo un poco muchas veces solapan estos
los he ido comentando especialmente los sistemas como hemos estado a diarios y demás ahí es porque
el tiempo de procesamiento ya es lento entonces como que no no te aprieta tanto perder el tiempo
ahí no el problema es cuando es un intradía que a lo mejor pues evaluarlo cuesta muchas horas de
optimización y ahí sí que ya pues es oye si lo ves quieres antes hacer algo sencillo para que te
se vaya de medios y no si no lo pasa no si no lo pasen no te van a perder un mes de trabajo no
decir algo que más una vez tenemos un sistema finalizado y queremos pasarlo real como implementarlo
y que entre exceso para que operen varios activos diferentes en hecho sistema como se hace
bueno esto no en sí en varios activos no tiene mayor dificultad lo que es recomendable yo yo
entiendo ejo a manuel que queráis concreto pero es que al final si si el curso sea el curso como
decía antes no puede ser un curso de trevín agrémico un curso de tres station un curso
de multichars un curso de msa un curso de cuan analyzer un curso de excel no puede porque
es cada una de esas cosas podrían ser 30 horas o más me explico entonces ya intentaré daros ya ya
lo he ido haciendo y lo haré a medida que me lo vais pidiendo por ejemplo de maestro que te he
dicho te voy a subir un material vale iré iré subiendo algunas cosas sí que os recomiendo es
verdad que son antiguos algunos de ellos bueno son antiguos muchos de ellos en nuestra web en
nuestra página web hay nuestra antigua época que éramos el soporte de tres station pues
teníamos bastantes vídeos y materiales os recomiendo ver este de presentación a tres
station 10 que abarca un poco de todo y luego están todos estos de nuevo y medio pero que también
estén en estaría de la 10 lo que pasa que no me consta que ser en castellano por eso están los de
nuevo y medio vale esta serie de aprende tres station es una serie que va haciendo tres station
recurrentemente pero a menos no me consta que la hayan hecho en inglés en español otra vez a
mejor ya lo han hecho y ojalá y si lo veo ahora pues mira lo ponemos en la web pero a mí no me
consta entonces es el problema la podéis hacer en la que el que lo hace en inglés le pone subtítulos
y es recomendable vale pero si no pues puede ver a no y medio que es verdad que no es igual no claro
que no es igual pero bueno puedes ver cositas que te pueden servir de referencia y hay muchas que
son iguales o sea cambia un poco el interface y tal pero la manera de hacer las cosas en algunos
cosas son bastante parecidos incluso hay unos webinars nuestros que los di yo también aquí
de tres station pero nuevamente es con la no y medio entonces ya digo es un tema que son antiguos
ves la plataforma y es antigua vale pero bueno ya os iré ya os iré facilitando el material que
pueda que vea que os puede ayudar sobre esto pero de momento os recomendaría a aquellos que estéis
muy muy verdes entre ese show ver este vídeo que es un resumen de la serie 10 en castellano y si no
pues lo que os digo ver la serie en inglés verla verla en inglés pero buscar ver dónde está esta
serie esto que tenga startet vale que esta es la que tenga startet de tres que es la que la que
van haciendo y bueno pero el problema es eso que ya digo en español por las hacen de uvas a peras y
ahora hace años que no quiero la hacen vale ese es el único problema que tiene vale sigo sigo
con las con las preguntas que creo que son importantes y que ayudará a todos
embran mínimo de tres en diario para que se pueda optimizar bueno esto siempre depende de acuerdo
siempre depende en principio un sistema en diario a a priori piensa que no se puede optimizar y que
si tienen muy pocos inputs y ya o ya es un veterano que ya lo has hecho antes y demás
sabes que has podido mantenerlo robusto pues puede ser esa esa cantidad esa cantidad que
das podría ser razonable es razonable vale es razonable una referencia que puedes coger son
30 50 trades por grado de libertad vale entonces ahí es que depende mucho porque tú ves es un
diario pero no me dices si tienes siete inputs entonces o uno tienes uno pues normalmente vas
bien vale pero de todo eso hemos hablado mucho en la teoría monel yo creo que hemos hablado
mucho de ello de acuerdo en toda la parte de optimización y demás qué fines elegir para
cada sistema y su opt y por qué condiciones para elegir unos votos en un sistema en cuáles
sentarnos en tse o multichar sortino ulcer y los tres favoritos bueno también se ha comentado
también se ha comentado entre station nosotros usamos tse expectancy score y ppc en multichar
usamos sortino o sortino ajustado vamos ulcer hemos usado también tse y hemos usado expectancy
hemos usado ppc también programados o sea vale es decir es que al final yo si me dices quedarme
con uno en multichar me quedaría con sortino probablemente a mí me gusta el sortino ajustado
que es aquello que os expliqué multiplicado por raíz de 2 porque al final te permite compararlo
para hacerlo compararlo con ser pero si más vale que es max bar el max bar es el parámetro mínimo
que necesita un gráfico para parar si tienes cuenta entre station esto te vas a la ayuda
y no sé si por max bar lo voy a contar porque eso al final sabes qué pasa que te acostumas a
llamarlo de una manera si bueno este es el de si maximum bars back setting vale esto es
máximo un bars back setting en la ayuda lo tienes en la ayuda lo tienes así que también hay que
buscar un poquito y no no lo digo porque yo no te lo puedo decir jamón el porque es importante
cultivar esa inquietud y esa mentalidad crítica de buscar las cosas vale hay que hacerlo vale
o sea no sólo estas y no dudas si estas plantillas estas plantillas en través salida con código de
él si esto es lo que os digo que veremos partes de búsqueda y si cuando lo veremos os lo daremos
si si si al principio todo el código que sale os lo damos si nos lo damos recordarnos lo porque
se me ha olvidado entonces porque el hacer el hacer un curso con un profesional que se dedica
esto tiene creo yo mi opinión muchas ventajas pero tiene también una pequeña desventaja vale
que por eso es luego cierta comprensión que es que yo le meto muchísimas horas al curso no
sabéis cuántas no sabéis cuántas pero claro también tengo que dedicarme a la actividad
principal de la compañía entendéis entonces no puedo abandonarla entendéis durante todo este
tiempo porque si no pues sería complicado entonces ese es el inconveniente que no es una persona que
sólo se dedica a hacer formación a cambio pues pues sabéis que habláis con alguien que sabe de
qué habla que tendrás que cometer a sus errores que se habrá equivocado mil veces que será mejor
será peor pero que sabe de qué porque lo ha pasado entonces esa es la ventaja la desventaja es que no
puede estar el cien por cien del tiempo dedicado a yo entonces a veces que se me olvidan cosas y
puede pasar así que en eso sí que os pido un poquito de de comprensión pero sí sí esto lo
daremos esto lo daremos vale la representación autosample de ambos lados siempre se coge más 25
menos 25 y eso que me descoge más 30 no sé qué vas a hacer para que el periodo no no no no no
no siempre por defecto el consenso coge más bien 30 realmente depende de los cortes esto yo no sé si
jose manuel es que no has acabado la teoría o demás pero te recomiendo volver a verla porque
es normal yo de hecho recomiendo a todos que la veis varias veces porque la habéis pagado y desde
que acabemos la práctica ya sabes que hay un año hay un año desde que acabemos la práctica garantizado
no quiere decir que al año hay un reloj vamos a cortar hay que garantizar a un tiempo y es el que
garantizamos vale entonces y y no eso está que te he visto y hablado en la teoría es que no has
acabado la teoría o demás pero te recomiendo volver a verla porque es normal yo de hecho recomiendo
a todos que la veis varias veces porque la habéis pagado y desde que acabemos la práctica
ya sabes que hay un año hay un año desde que acabemos la práctica garantizado no quiere decir
que la representación autosample de ambos lados siempre se coge más 25 menos 25 y eso que me
descoge más 30 no sé qué vas a hacer para que el periodo no no no no no no siempre por defecto el
consenso coge más bien 30 realmente depende de los cortes esto yo no sé si jose manuel es que no
has acabado la teoría o demás pero te recomiendo volver a verla porque es normal yo de hecho
recomiendo a todos que la veis varias veces porque la habéis pagado y desde que acabemos la práctica
ya sabes que hay un año vale hay un año desde que acabemos la práctica garantizado no quiere
decir que al año hay un reloj vamos a cortar hay que garantizar a un tiempo y es el que
garantizamos entonces y no esto está arre que te he visto y hablado en la teoría hicimos alguna
práctica viendo los cortes y la práctica yo creo que ya se ha visto y se verá también no depende
un poquito de los cortes o sea de donde tú veas que cortas el histórico pero sí que el consenso
en cuando hacemos optimización podemos decir convencional pues suele estar ahí en 30% 25 30
por ejemplo pardo también hace una prueba que es 50 50 hace 50 y 50 por los dos lados eso que
hacemos nosotros 25 25 que puede ser 30 30 no no importa no no no no no está ahí la gran la
gran diferencia vale wall forward es descalificante si la óptima clásica es buena wall forward desde
cero en práctica sí sí claro que lo veremos en el curso se dice que es más difícil que en
temporalidades altas pasar wall forward no bueno si dije eso no lo dije bien en temporalidades
altas lo que pasa es que es difícil pasar wall forward porque no hay trades para hacer tantos
cortes al final wall forward cluster que es el que a mí me gusta consiste en hacer muchos cortes
entonces claro no hay trades para hacer si tú tienes 300 trades como me decías y encima lo
cortas en 20 trozos pues claro que va a quedar todo con dificultad de que sea comparable entonces
es difícil por eso también es verdad que depende del tipo de sistema lo comentaba que alejandro
cree una vez que él no le gustaba el wall forward por eso porque en un tendencial pasa épocas que
si pocas que no es verdad por eso los cortes tienen que ser lo suficientemente amplios en ese
caso para que haya de todo claro esto esto hay cosas que se cogen un poquito con la práctica
que para eso es la práctica y con la experiencia lógicamente es decir por eso yo todo el mundo que
me ha preguntado os he dicho el que esté empezando de cero yo creo que puede salir adelante y tener
una formación fantástica y quedar muy contento al final del curso pero que tampoco esperes que
acabes el curso ya seas el máster del universo porque hay que hay que practicar es decir hay que
tener experiencia propia tienes y al final aquí no se trata de coger los 10 15 o los 20 sistemas
que hagamos y llevarlos a mercado se trata de que cojáis mané de que veáis maneras de conseguir
las cosas como hacerlas para vosotros que vayáis haciendo vosotros mismos que esa es la gracia que
vosotros mismos vayáis haciendo cosas y aportando y además en el disco por ejemplo que hay bastante
participación pues también se ve eso no me ha gustado mucho todo este intercambio de papers que
ahora vamos a hablar de ello vale muy interesante muy interesante que lo hagáis y lo aportáis incluso
a lo mejor aportarís algo una vez alguna cosa que a mí no me gusta pues oye así es la vida que
decir da lo mismo si lo aportáis aquí o no porque lo veréis igual fuera es decir está bien que lo
aportes porque si algo que no me gusta pues lo podré opinar me quieres decir quiero decir que
al final está bien que todo el mundo participe en él en él en el disco y aporte lo que buenamente
pueda y pregunte porque eso al final enriquece a más gente siempre siempre en cualquier tozo ahora
mismo en este rollo que estoy hay gente que está pensado fue el puto palo que está llevamos una
hora de clase y todavía no ha dicho nada que me resulta interesante y hay otro grupo diciendo
qué buena la clase de hoy qué bien que estamos repasando preguntas básicas tienes esto es así
cada día porque es normal porque somos muchos y hay perfiles distintos pero a mí yo cuando hago yo
por ejemplo empecé el duolingo a hacer hacer el inglés yo sé un poquito de inglés y empecé de
cero empecé de cero me hizo el test y le contesté todo mal para que me empezara de cero porque me
gusta repasar la base porque coges vicios tal entonces viene bien viene bien hasta hasta el que
sabe un montón en las cosas básicas coge cosas coge pocas cosas pero el diablo está los detalles
no se olvide el diablo está los detalles y poco a veces pocos cosas que son no muy importantes son
muy importantes entonces yo a mí en mi opinión es así que viene bien hasta repasar las cosas
más básicas a veces porque aunque sepas porque ya digo a lo mejor te llevas hasta estas sorpresas
bueno haremos gol forward claro que haremos gol forward claro que sí y temporales altas
preguntas aquí en qué umbrales mínimos nos deberíamos mover para saber hasta qué punto
renta intentar pasarlo yo creo que es bueno y tratar de pasarlo es bueno y tratar de pasarlo
pasa que si hay lo que os comenté que hay un mínimo de trades por cluster que el consenso
fijan 30 si tienes muchos clusters no es malo ese 30 es 50 mejor pero el 30 es bien es bien sí
hay muchos clusters porque no es que sean 30 son 30 más 30 más 30 más 30 más 30 más 30 entonces
ese sería un mínimo pero lo ideal es que sea más claro es que sea más pero esa es un poco la
referencia que los clusters puedas tener mínimo de 33 de media duda sobre él sería posible que nos
enseñaras el código de un sistema al llegar a x profit mensual deja de operar así como ver el
código de un tp loco siempre claro que sí eso no tiene ninguna ninguna dificultad y su explicación
de cuándo sería recomendable implementarlo vale esto donde lo podíamos explicar alberto pero cuando
hagamos algún sistema tipo iris igual no alberto cuando vamos a un sistema tipo iris igual así
de semanal mensual podemos podemos meter esto de tp loco y el profit mensual yo creo que ahí puede
encajar bien sí sí sí bueno profit mensual en sí sí no tiene tampoco es excesiva dificultad y
el tp loco no es más que el tp loco es literal es literal es un tp pues muy superior a la historia
hasta el finales mirando el mfl el maxin favorable excursión en una muestra de muchos años con muchos
tres en una muestra muy muy larga no pero un poquito donde donde el sistema tiene profits
realmente desbocados donde sale madre pues un poco es ahí acuerdo es zonas donde creemos que
renta a salirse pero ya digo si tú tienes a esto yo nuevamente lo aplicaría solo más bien en
cartera más bien cuando tengo llevas ante sistemas no es lo mismo tener un sistema o por ejemplo
cuando me pongo a hablar de los revés no es lo mismo saldrá una cosa no que es que decir bueno
cómo lo configuró me renta cortos no cortos ya lo comentaba la teoría y lo hago de la práctica
es decir muchas veces lo que tú buscas depende de lo que ya tienes porque lo que quieres es lo
que no tienes la mejor manera de diversificar es es por estrategia entonces yo si estoy buscando
un no es de bebe porque ya tengo una cartera de sistemas que van bien en medio largo plazo
incluso entraría en el largo en el largo pues a lo mejor me interesa el corto a lo mejor me
interesa el corto y a lo mejor no es el mejor lado del sistema pero bueno yo prefiero que no sea
tan bueno pero prefiero que vaya corto porque porque sé que me va a diversificar mejor el
porfolio entonces hay un poco lo que lo que quieres entonces aquí este tipo de cosas te peló
cosas de cartera yo solo los aplicaría en caso que tuviera ya una cartera de sistemas que me
garantizan que que no me voy a perder un momento porque hay que vigilar porque es el tp loco si
te si te vas a salir de las reglas del sistema que un poco te está saliendo haciendo eso
tienes que tener algo que te cubra es decir o dicho o dicho de otra manera no se lo si yo
tengo cinco sistemas a lo mejor dos les pongo tp loco y tres no entiendes es decir es un poco
la idea si solo tengo uno pues no lo aplico si solo tengo dos seguramente tampoco si tengo
tres a lo mejor uno me entiendes es decir no no no todo porque al final también eso hay que
diversificarlo que diversificarlo todo es pero bueno lo veremos me apuntas alberto me apuntas
el profit mensual que deje de operar código y tp loco vale y bueno ya estaría ya estaría estas
preguntas bastante interesantes de juan manuel y me queda ya comentaba que alberta esa no la
tenía aquí apuntada una de las dudas que tengo en relación a los valores umbrales de las funciones
fitness que utilizamos para evaluar un sistema a partir de qué valor umbral podemos considerar que
recovery factor es bueno la misma con el profit factor el ratio total return máximo y demás
funciones con seres más relevantes gracias bueno hicimos una clase de umbrales que es verdad que
tampoco fue que dieran así que di unas referencias pero no es que no soy mi amigo al ver de las
tres referencias súper estrictas de acuerdo no soy no soy mi amigo porque no no están dos a
nosotros ya digo yo tengo temas operando que tienen referencias que son flojas pero luego pues
las mantienen y la y la hay una cierta parte de la industria que que busca referencias para mí
demasiado altas porque ya asume que le degradan mucho bueno quizá mejor había que pensar en que
no degradarán tanto sabes y a lo mejor el camino para que no degraden tanto es que no sean tan
buenas entonces es un poco relativo iremos viendo en la práctica qué datos obtenemos y ya habéis
visto muchas veces en mis en mis en mis directos y demás pues los datos que nosotros obtenemos
entonces ya digo al final en el backtest es fácil obtener cosas súper heavies pero pero no no no es
el camino vale de todas maneras sí que las que di estoy por aquí para que para no decir lo distinto
a lo que dije estoy mirando a ver aquí donde tengo mis notas sobre lo que dije las algunas
referencias que vimos no vimos alguna algunas referencias alguna referencia también depende del
tipo de datos porque no es lo mismo que el dato venga por ejemplo yo que sé que sea optimizado
que sea de operativas real o que sea de un monte carlo vale que al final suele dividirlo
por dos entonces es relativo pero no sé o sea un recovery factor que viene a ser un
retorno partido por drawdown sí que dos veces tres veces suele ser un parámetro en datos fíjate que
en datos anualizados pues frecuentemente está parecido el dato anualizado del drawdown es decir
15 anualizado 15 es ideal que sea un poco mayor neto y operativas reales hablando operativas
real no de backtest esa es una referencia que no es que a mí me gusta mirar por ejemplo el
caso del drawdown que sea mayor que el drawdown que el drawdown sea menor que el profit no es
una referencia mínima sería referencia podemos decir mínima en el performance report es una
referencia mínima en el performance report que el drawdown sea menor que el total profit en valor
absoluto no es una referencia mínima de ahí para arriba profit factor es lo que te digo
colegas 4 3 2 vale muy bien si es de real pues de 1 y medio por encima ya es correcto con
comisiones realistas pesimistas por encima 1 y medio 2 está correcto está correcto y si
es operativa real por encima de 1 es perfecto operativa real entonces es todo es todo un poquito
relativo y cambia mucho de que de que miramos si miramos datos optimizados miramos operativas
real miramos de carlo depende un poquito pero eso es un poquito unas referencias que te puedo
dar y que había dado que habíamos dado en otros durante la teoría creo que tenía una más
saber la verdad por aquí a ver para ir acabando a ver a esto era esto era no franza franza no sé
dónde dónde lo ha puesto esto franza a franco la puesto aquí en preguntas del curso vale y mira
ya les amarrug le ha contestado esto esto me gusta esto me gusta que os que os vayáis que
os vayáis esto franza si queréis preguntar preguntar pregunta aquí y si queréis charlar
entre vosotros por lo del bar que así así mola que no no pasa nada aquí no pasa nada aquí porque
tampoco pasa nada pero pero bueno es un poquito porque todo el mundo aquí este este claro si
tampoco pretendía si contestáramos nosotros ya sabe pero donde tenemos en contestar seguros aquí
pregunta aquí se ve aquí arriba lo explica un poco todo vale franza comentaba estaba repasando
las funciones fitness y le ha venido una idea loca a la cabeza partiendo del sqn cojo este porque
ya tenemos aplicado una corrección por el número de operaciones correcto aunque se podrían coger
el ratio de sortino simplificado filtrando los sets que tengan menos x operaciones y multiplica
por barras o días en drawdown barras o días totales del histórico con esta multiplicación
penalizamos los sets que están más tiempo en drawdown aplanando las curvas pregunta si
tiene sentido puede ser una forma de sobreatomizar ya que tenemos los sets que más se ajustan en la
curva aunque supere wall forward optimizer mira hay mucha gente que tiene ratios fitness personalizados
no está mal hacerlo vale no está mal hacerlo solo os diría que no o perdáis la cabeza con ello
es decir no penséis que es su que va a estar ahí la gran clave de que contraeis un sistema robusto
lógicamente la función fitness tiene su importancia pero dentro de las que ya habéis visto tienes
soluciones de hecho lo que tú has explicado tienes un rato que ya lo hace que se llama ulcer index
acaba de explicar que penalizan los sets que están más tiempo en drawdown aplanando las curvas eso
exactamente es lo que hace ulcer index y al final ulcer index es lo mismo ha hecho
así casi juraría que lo que lo comenté pero déjame repasar el por pon que usaba yo de guión
que lo voy a buscar aquí en la en el buscador y lo comparto pero estoy bastante convencido sí
que hablé de un sqn un sqn corregido y lo hice un poco como para que reflexionar es donde está
el buscador aquí para que reflexionar es como tú muy bien has hecho fran aquí esto es lo que yo
usaba que esto es lo de recordar que en el en el en la teoría de bajo en la teoría de bajo hay
otros vídeos porque lo habéis visto que está el poder por entero todo el poder que yo he usado
es lo que os lo he dado entero hay mucho material y algunas de las cosas que preguntáis de material
están ahí aquí cuando vimos ese cuenememos upi que viene del ulcer index vale hablamos mucho de
volatilidad y hablamos mucho de char que es el estándar de la industria aquí aquí y mira
ahí que ve que tienes abajo mira que tienes abajo ahí mejor no nos habíais dado cuenta a lo mejor no
lo comenté a ver el puntero láser aquí es ahí ese cuen es simplificado raíz ese cuen con ulcer
beneficio medio partido por ulcer multiplicado por raíz de trade eso es bastante parecido a lo
que has hecho tú o ese cuen es sortino partido por la desviación de negativos y es que al final
es todo es poco lo mismo de acuerdo todo es un poco lo mismo retorno y riesgo y hay distintas
maneras de medirlo entonces más o menos ya tienes todo lo que lo que hay ulceria mide eso que tú que
tú pides vale y y soltino medir la desviación de negativos entonces ahí tienes un poquito ya
pero no está nada mal lo que has hecho nada mal está bastante está perfectamente correcto yo lo
le veo no le veo no lo veo mal no veo que o sea no creo que eso te favorezca la sobre optimización
y mucho menos sobre optimización te lo va a favorecer tener poco straight en una muestra mala
pero ese fitness en sí no tiene nada de malo al final tienes retorno y tienes riesgo y el
riesgo también es estar a tiempo de hablar como y de hecho como te digo lo mide ulcer index así
que para mí es correcto no no le veo ningún problema a ver qué le decías a marrón que
mi opinión tiene sentido pero no habría que multiplicarlo por el inverso es decir ratio
secuenes sortino barras o días o tardes del histórico partido por barras o días en draw
ya digo al final numerador el retorno riesgo denominado o sea es un poco la idea porque
al final de eso que eres que divida no que reste entonces pero también hay ratios que
restan o sea que hay muchas y hay roto omega y acordaros la plática que os hice con con
sortino que vimos el upside ratio también que es la derivada de sortino que os enseñe la web
donde estaba y todo esto todos estos papers son realmente interesantes vale bien ya fin de
preguntas de momento vale de la parte de la parte del disco vale bien hoy quería empezar
bueno empezar sólo así de cuarto pero quería la clase de hoy ya lógicamente seguiremos con
esto como ya sabéis como como vamos funcionando teníamos bastante preparado
pero aunque el tema sobre el sobre 1rb de hecho ya que estábamos en el disco pues hubo al comentarlo
la semana pasada han habido varias aportaciones varias aportaciones es en el justamente
dejó un pay un paper aquí que es interesante aunque bueno es un estudio es un estudio que
es que es interesante pero como muchos estudios académicos a veces pues como que le falta un
poquito de bajarlo al suelo a mí es decir al final falta un poquito de bajarlo al suelo está
bien esa bien pero podrías ya haberlo llevado un poco más más lejos y hacerlo ya estrategia
como tal y demás no porque pero bueno está bien o sea final de evaluar un poco la ventaja y está
bien está bien está bien si le dais a ellos lo baja y ahí lo tenéis y es un paper bastante
interesante de hecho o alberto se ha preparado que ahora os lo voy a subir ahí os voy a subir
en el material y también lo subiremos al discord os ha preparado un pequeño resumen del paper en
castellano vale para que no sé si lo ha hecho sólo él lo ha hecho con la ayuda de gpt yo para
usar resúmenes a veces lo uso aunque aunque a veces va bien y a veces no sé no sé si interés
experiencia con pero a veces me saca de quicio porque a veces resume mucho es que no dice nada y
a veces es útil es una cosa que yo para hacer resúmenes a veces sí que lo uso y pues no sé
si la verdad lo ha hecho sólo con ayuda de gpt con ayuda no vale que con ayuda pero pero
bueno aquí está aquí está ahora os lo subiré os lo voy a hacer pdf y os lo subo os lo subo aquí
a la plataforma vale ese es el paper que han habido más nosotros no tenemos ocasión de leerlos no sé
si si haber todos los ha leído bueno aquí ha habido bastante bastante debate sobre el
tema está muy bien bueno si está bien pero hay que hay que probarlo y demás y tal no
y bueno pues aquí ha enseñado to paper a vale este era otro este era otro también de la de los
mios autores no habéis estado ahí dándole este no lo he visto este la verdad que no le no tiene
ocasión de leerlo este no tenía ocasión de leerlo no sé no sé cómo está ya lo ya le echaré un
vistazo mañana se lo has visto todo abierto no no no es el 22 es el 22 es el 22 también es el 22
pero es el que tengo que mirar también no lo no lo he visto ya os lo os lo miraré y aquí Alejandro
añadió bueno si si es que de verdad hay semanas que se hace un fallar es una cosa técnicamente
y aquí se suelta cuatro artículos más venga no este ya estaba este es repetido se suelta cuatro
pues nada ya me los intentaré de mirar todos a mira eso es en castellano es el mismo en castellano
es a pos mira está muy bien no ya lo tenéis ahí tenéis ahí bueno bien que es vamos a empezar a
hablar de las estrategias rv vale nosotros tenemos varias varias fuentes una de las que más uso yo
de consulta ya lo comentaba muchas veces el libro de cauma que veis ahí de hecho ahí se ve ahí vale
que está es barba muy muy completo que tiene prácticamente de todo y bueno al final
también he hecho esto sí que lo he intentado yo hacer un par de resúmenes con gpt que es lo que
digo algunas cosas me las he resumido muchos algunas hasta las he extendido un poco yo pero
os he hecho un par de resúmenes de los temas que tiene en los dos libros que tengo de caufman de
los sistemas entradiarios y rb y demás vale que también los voy a pasar ahora os los os los pondré
tengo dos son muy parecidos lógicamente vale son muy son dos son muy parecidos y me quiero
quedar con este a ver un momentito donde está extra me guión si no lo estabais viendo que está
estaba estaba arriba yo perdonar es que hoy me he cambiado el monitor abajo para intentar mirar
menos arriba porque hay momentos que no me doy cuenta y estoy estoy mostrándole arriba entonces
perdonar pero parece que lleva un rato y un rato mostrando arriba y no y no se veía no bueno
os decía que tengo que os hemos hecho tres documentos hoy uno todos de day trading que
proviene de los libros de caban es una es una el resumen que he tratado de hacer con con gpt y
de los libros de caufman vale dándole pegando el material alguno lo he alargado yo porque lo
resumía tanto que sobre todo este el esquema que se me gusta mucho este lo he traducido y lo
he hecho entero vale porque porque es que de verdad lo traducía mucho ahí lo reducía mucho
entonces digo pues nada lo he pegado vale y lo he puesto los demás que hay un capítulo y una
línea dos pero ya digo estos dos y la traducción del paper que ha hecho alberto también os la os
la os la os la pongo os la pongo ahí y mira voy a hacerlo ahora ya un momentito dame un segundo
un segundo porque bueno mira sabes qué voy a hacer voy a seguir lo en la pausa luego vale la
pausa luego porque si no no no hay manera de avanzar vale en manera de avanzar porque sí que
tengo para poco una definición vale la definición de una estrategia o rb clásica se le viene a eso
y hacer esto pero esto es un poco un rb clásico unos revés no deja de ser un sistema principio
intradiliario vale un sistema de breakout que utiliza el rango principalmente de apertura pero
no sólo se puede hacer con el cierre empezando en el cierre anterior empezando con empezando con la
apertura que es uno típico o simplemente ignorando el periodo de acuerdo ignorando el periodo sino
un breakout que tengo uno otro preparado que yo creo que no nos nos dará y seguramente lo haremos
el próximo día un breakout que no es open breakout vale porque uno es revés al final un opening
range breakout pues puede ser un volatilidad breakout directo pero sin centrarse en el opening no
al final un sistema intradiliario es muy parecido a un sistema diario simplemente tiene un paro
tres de características que lo hacen especial y dos o tres cositas que suelen ir muy bien en
los sistemas interdiarios y que ahora os voy os voy a contar que lógicamente que tiene especial
primero es decidir en qué time frame lo operamos acuerdo esa es la primera característica obligatoria
en un en un sistema interdiario porque en un diario pues el diario semanal no hay debate en
un en un interdiario lo puedo poner en un minuto en 5 el 10 15 20 30 en 60 y ahí está el debate
está el conflicto puede ir hay gente muy partidaria de usar divisiones exactas con la con las horas
decir que todas garantizarse que todas las velas del día sean iguales para lo cual tenemos que
hacer un múltiplo de normalmente 30 o por ejemplo 30 o 15 porque ahí con de 30 en 30 normalmente
cuadra pero en estados unidos de futuros por ejemplo no porque el usuario acaba a normal es
acabar 10 y cuarto no no hay en nuestro entonces ahí ya tienes que ir si quieres hacer eso tienes
que ir 15 minutos o 5 minutos porque si no no cuadras y en cambio en europa así que con 30
pues suele ser poder cuadrar hay gente cambio muy partidaria de que sean divisores de 60 que
siempre sean divisores de 60 vale entonces que todos los números se puedan llevar a 60 entonces
a mí por ejemplo particularmente me gusta usar time frames raros también nos digo que no no no es
la gran decisión que no es la cosa más importante para nada es una casi anecdótica pero como es
anecdótica me gusta salirme porque porque al final como normalmente yo en este tipo de sistema
no voy a considerar las noticias como tal que es una es un sistema que está basado en pautas de
precio una manera de esquivar las noticias es no coincidir con las horas en punto de acuerdo no
coincidir porque las noticias se suelen dar hay 30 en punto vale con alguna excepción las noticias
me refiero a las conocidas luego hay imprevistos vale entonces una manera es esa no es usar 21
minutos 23 28 nosotros por ejemplo nemesis actualmente lo operamos en 28 de acuerdo nemesis
ahora lo operamos en 28 hemos operado en 21 hemos operado en 60 y pico en 90 y tantas vale es decir
pero bueno tengo reconozco la manía y otra manía que tengo es para un porque esto ya lo hace
bastante gente para ser para alejar para no coincidir con esa otra gente es que la mi división no
es no es exacta con con las horas del mercado todas las horas de mercado las puedes contar no
yo que sé por ejemplo el s p ahora hablo de memoria para que son 500 o no son 450 minutos
creo abierto no 450 el s p no es regular ahora hablo de memoria 24 horas son 1440
pues 23 son 60 menos no falla y bueno ahí vas vas calculando bueno es igual ahora no importa
las que sean entonces tú calculas la división exacta y puedes buscar más o menos algún número
que te cuadre que no hay muchos que cuadran de cuidado pero a mí lo que me gusta es que la
última sea cercana cercana a ser completa pero sin llegar a serlo de acuerdo es una manía es decir
ha sido un periodo que seguramente usa poca gente seguramente usa poca y así que ahora habrá uno
pero no es bueno para hacerse la gente bueno para cosas y para cosas entonces nosotros en
este caso preferimos usar un periodo un periodo pues más más raro vale pero insisto que no es
algo súper importante no es algo súper importante dos cosas más cosas más que hay que definir en
un sistema lo hablaba antes no recuerdo con qué pregunta hablaba de la y lo comentaba luego lo
hablaremos en la clase hablando de los reves tendencialidad no tendencialidad cuando hablamos
de periodos de más largo plazo normalmente hay más tendencialidad que lógicamente los hay más que
otros pero pero es más fácil a medida que bajamos pasa lo contrario ya empieza a predominar más el
revertir pero aún así también hay más tendenciales que otros también los hay más tendenciales que
otros que suele ser más tendencial de entraría los bonos pueden ser más tendenciales por ejemplo
puede ser un poco más limpios suelen también hay momentos y momentos pero suele serlo y en general
las acciones son muy poco tendenciales muy poco pero también es más tendencial el nasdaq el daujan
o es más tendencial el dax que le bros tos que eso para coger tendencia a los tos eso es una mole
eso no hay quien lo mueva 50 mil contratos en cada en cada posición bueno entiendes que al final
bueno pues hay más pero si tú tienes un revertir pues a lo mejor te va mejor los tos
el boom o que el tibón entonces al final ahí hay activos lógicamente esto hay que mirarlo
otra cosa que es más importante en intradía que en diario o que se suele dar más importancia es
a la volatilidad y al volumen que muchas veces son caras de la misma moneda de acuerdo es decir
cuando sube el volumen sube la volatilidad cuando sube la volatilidad sube el volumen
muy frecuentemente estas dos magnitudes van de la mano de acuerdo muy frecuentemente estas
magnitudes dos magnitudes van de la mano de volatilidad y volumen en intradía es suelen
ser filtros útiles recordar que en intradía suelo tener muchos trades no me resulta complicado
conseguir 2000 3000 5000 trades de acuerdo y por tanto es fácil que tenga margen para filtrar
con criterio pero tengo más margen vale porque me es más fácil conseguir significación me es más
fácil conseguir representatividad de la muestra bueno sobre todo lo que me es más fácil es
conseguir significación conseguir representatividad es más fácil en diario de hecho vale bien entonces
volumen y volatilidad uno u otro vale porque si no ya digo suelen ser la misma cosa suelen ser la
misma cosa tampoco vamos a machacar ahí poner ahora filtro de volumen filtro de volatilidad y
filtro de todo vale también es bastante habitual no estas son cosas que estoy comentando no quiere
decir que sea obligatorio contando tips dando tips que se suelen usar más bien en intradía que en
el diario otra cosa que se suele usar mucho en intradía es ventanas temporales de acuerdo
ventanas temporales yo tengo un gráfico de como decía en acciones pues tampoco son tantos minutos
pero si yo tengo por ejemplo el nasdaq y lo tengo en horario continuo pues al final tengo como os
decía antes pues 1400 minutos o por ahí no puedo elegir donde los operó no tengo por qué operarlos
todos a lo mejor me interesa una ventana concreto también en las divisas se usa mucho también en
las divisas se usa se usa mucho operar unas determinadas ventanas europea por ejemplo eurex
que lo tenía por aquí creo preparado a no pues nada antes para variar no sé qué ha pasado que
hemos abierto el multichart se ha ido todo a tomar viento a la farola y me parece que ha abierto el
que no era este es este es el que va con el dax a ver si el dax yo lo puedo abrir aquí por
ejemplo yo lo tengo cargado con una sesión que creo que se ure si que va de 8 a 10 de la noche
pero no sé porque ya lo sabéis un día porque europa siempre ha decidido porque como estados
siempre tomó una decisión de abrir mucho aunque cuidado lo hace los futuros no me he contado al
final europa como que hay que abrir cuanto más mejor y un día decidió abrir a las dos de la mañana
perdón a la una que es una decisión en mi opinión muy acertada muy acertada sin duda alguna se ha
tenido un éxito total está todo el mundo peleándose desde las de la una de la mañana a
la seta de la mañana operando el dax alemán normalmente a dejaros que hay unos movimientos
tremendos de vértigo en unos movimientos de vértigo es sinonía por si alguien no lo había
por si alguien no lo había pillado vale además esto es una putada porque te cambia las propiedades
marcado se va de locos de locos movimientos tremendos una locura ella en un trading de
calidad y ese es para morir a las marmotas ahí y eso bastida es todos los días igual todos los días
igual la misma tontería ahí no se mueve nada no se mueve nada para uno mira aquí hombre para un
día que se mueve es que hay hasta velas hasta velas de 10 minutos casi sin volumen un contrato
un contrato sabes decir en el dax es de chiste y eso es el grande ya no sé los minis y eso
no deben ni moverse bueno entonces bueno pues tú eliges no tú eliges donde operar tú eliges
donde operar y es frecuente hacerlo frecuente hacerlo vía cambiando la sesión ya por el código
del sistema como tú quieras pero tú puedes elegir donde operar en europa lo más habitual
es empezar a 8 o 9 no os calentéis en empezar en empezar antes pero también se podría hacer y
en eeuu hay gente que lo hace podemos probarlo o sea con este reveló lo podemos jugar quiero
decir que podría hacer y en estado 9 ya cambiando la sesión ya por el código del sistema como tú
eliges no tú eliges donde operar tú eliges donde operar y es frecuente hacerlo frecuente hacerlo
vía cambiando la sesión ya por el código del sistema como tú quieras pero tú puedes elegir
donde operar en europa lo más habitual es empezar a 8 o 9 no os calentéis en empezar en empezar
antes pero también se podría hacer y en eeuu hay gente que lo hace podemos probarlo
o sea con este reveló lo podemos jugar quiero decir en que tú puedes hacer un rango que sea
la primera este este que hemos hecho entrada que es una versión de caos ahora os enseñaré
el original es parte del rango de la primera hora que es una foto muy típica la primera hora se usa
de rango y por cierto yo que eso ya os lo daremos el código que como se ha dicho el original es
de caos man pero hemos desarrollado uno propio pues ya os dejo ahí abierta a aquellos que sepáis
problemar o que empecéis a hacer pinitos que haga eso contrario vale haga eso contrario es decir esto
es un open range breakout por qué no porque no tengo la indicadora aquí pintado si lo tenía
es que está off venga a no a por el por lo de la sesión alberto hay que evitarlo el
indicador es el verto no va tampoco claro a ver un segundín un segundín el indicador es este no
es m es éste no como no era lo de la sesión no te acuerdas de la función es la de la sesión
que tiene la antigua está de compatibilidad esa es la de apertura no pero uno no era es el código
original del campo es muy antiguo y usó unas palabras reservadas que ya no se usan que parece
ser que que petan parece que es 0 1 ha compilado si aquí aquí no como que no sé si es el otro
aquí no sé si ahora esto ya debería de funcionar si funcionan las narices funciona a ver
es que he cambiado la estrategia y cambié la estrategia alberto en un indicador he cambiado
la estrategia entonces para ver si estábais atentos no no no es normal ahora sí ahora sí ahora sí
esto pintaba el rango de la apertura no era alberto que lo voy a cargar ya el que toca que lo hemos
mirado desde urex bueno teníamos el original metido también verdad alberto si si vamos a
quitar el original el nuestro y vamos a poner de momento el original original con 10 con 10 esto
el 10 era el periodo de cierre verdad alberto del diario no entonces este lo que pasa que no
tiene ni el cierre a fin de día ni nada vale este va un poco va un poco así a pelo a eso
son el 23 no espérate que lo vamos a poner hasta hoy ya porque así se mueve a todo que tiene
su gracia también no saque de la red nos jodas a la tuya si yo parece que estoy el aire así si
bien entonces bueno este este este sistema de caos man que repito este es el original es
es esto que veis aquí es esto final usa tres datas del mismo activo 10 minutos 60 y diario
el 60 simplemente es para delimitar el el primer a la primera hora que es el rango es el rango
este que marca de apertura para el que cual opera y yo os decía vamos a verlo aquí esperar otra vez
hemos hecho la la de siempre la de cada día la de cada día como no tengo así todos los gráficos
pues no me acuerdo más está bien así está bien aquí pues mira hoy no operado le hemos puesto de
8 a 10 de 8 a 10 8 a 10 y ahora que no sé si hacer la pausita ahora era casi que os hago la
pausita ahora un momentito y ya los metemos un poco más a fondo ya vamos del tirón ya vamos del
tirón para para para el final vale así que os lo voy a poner ahora a poner cinco minutitos
cinco minutitos de pausita y así preparo los papers los dos ya vamos todos ahí a tope
voy a poner el reloj podéis ir a amelendar o lo que necesitéis ahí tengo los cursos abiertos
vamos ahí el relojito está aquí cinco minutos
pausa grabación donde se pasa la grabación venga estaba hablando aquí solo muy bien se les llevamos
me había silenciado en los dos sitios en el micro y en la plataforma entonces claro
no se me había a ver que estén los pd que he tenido que ir a ir a visitar al señor roca y
estaba medio a medio hacer los los pdfs los pdfs a ver esto lo vamos a hacer aquí material para
alumnos documentación un momentito documentación sistema de reventar ya os anticipo que vamos a
iniciar con esto una serie de sistemas de este tipo vamos a hacer una unos cuantos vamos a hacer
unos unos cuantos y el revés y el oeste porque no me lien que más que más esa deje entraría
uno a ver que quito ya esto pero se han corregido lo más del tanto a emitir ésta ahí vamos
y miráis de mi belleza incalculable vamos con el último hay dos que son muy parecidos
y os comentaba que están extraídos de cientos libros como que el hecho cual no he hecho este
noche una estrategia sin traer esto está bien los pongo ahí los tres los tres documentitos material
para alumnos comentación a ver si me deja para los tres a la vez 2 eba 3 bien seguimos
a ver esto que lo tenga bien que he visto que tenía malo la cosa y
esto no se ve muy bien aquí de que habíamos el color amarillo que se va un poco mejor estaba con
éste y ha tocado un poco las líneas para que las las vieres un poco mejor eso es el dax 12
a ver para lo que os decía antes vale volvemos al urb en aureli está está aquí en documentos
aquí mismo tienes un sitio donde hay documentos luego ya por la noche sino mañana te trae esta
noche subiros lo al discord pero bueno de momento lo tenéis aquí para los que estáis en la clase
en estrategias entre día 1 y 2 pues veis ahí si quieres abrir alguno abrir el 2 porque ahí el
2 tenéis ese esquema general que es esto que estaba diciendo ahora que bueno no ha ido bien
esto me cago en 10 que ha pasado así siempre porque no pasarás los esto y hoy fino fino 1 2 3 y 4
no vale el esquema general que es el que no no he evitado que lo tradujera porque que lo
redujera porque me quería que estuviera enterito vale y es lo que os decía antes no las pautas
horarias también habla y por ejemplo de eso mejor los resultados con más precisas de un
también filtros de este tipo no si hay pautas si hay pautas previas que hablan de la congestión
está muy usada está es muy muy usada vale no la tenemos puesta ahora pero ya la ya la pondremos
esta no la creo que no la hemos implementado en este pero esto es bastante bastante usual recordar
que el mercado sigue mucho el ciclo congestión expansión congestión expansión entonces si yo
busco expansión a un filtro muy bueno es ver que el día anterior ha habido contracción entonces
si tú evaluas eso con una pauta muy sencilla en la vela diaria que sea un en site bar que es
una en site bar es una vela que está toda ella dentro que ahora no se ve muy bien esta no lo
es por poco esta por ejemplo es una en site bar bueno no igual no tampoco pues no hay muchas
pero sabéis lo que es una que está completa dentro de la anterior vela todo el cuerpo como
se mira eso pues que el máximo de hoy sea inferior al máximo del día anterior y que el mínimo sea
mayor que el mínimo del día anterior eso es una en site bar en diario es comparando máximo con
máximo mínimo con mínimo y una en site bar pues lo contrario entonces en en pautas en sistemas
de breakout muchas veces se busca eso antes os comentaba os decía que java deberes no es que
cuando digo esto no es que ponga deberes pero os lo dejo para que reflexionéis esto al final
bueno antes veamos lo que hace este sistema mira vamos a verlo con este con este corto de aquí
vamos a entenderlo y una vez lo entendamos pues ya vamos a ir porque muchas líneas aquí en las
líneas que son punteadas las que marcan las señales de entrada lo único que cada man tiene
este no lo hemos tocado el nuestro sí que está tocado ahora lo veréis tiene fija una un rango
de 20 puntos extra para para entrar es decir es un breakout vale un rent breakout que le añade
20 puntos para para entrar entonces este este valor vale está fijado por la primera vela de 60
cuál es la primera vela de 60 esta es la de cierre esta es la de apertura vale esta es la de
apertura a ver si me puedo acercar más intentar hacer esto un poquito más grande luego ya lo haré
pequeño es la naranja vamos a hacerla más gorda porque esto creo que se va a ver poco y
vamos a hacerla bastante gruesa va a quedar raro pero bueno es igual eso es vale esta vela está
está vale ahí se ve bien ahora esta vela es la vela de apertura pero esta es la vela de apertura
también se ve poco jaimito cuando lo puedo pintar con la plataforma y así pues me va a ir
eso es esta vela es la apertura esta vela tiene un rango de máximo de 461 y de mínimo de 436 en
principio el sistema así como está ya lo explica el libro en su opción que no deja de ser una
muestra decir al final los sistemas prácticamente el 100% de los sistemas queda caos van a son
sistemas podemos decir completos el mismo ya el texto te sugiere cosas y tal o sea son poco
ideas para que tu explores este es el éxito en un mínimo aquí en 436 vale tiene 436 y vais
a ver cómo la venta como es menos 20 pues tiene que haber venido en 416 y bueno no igual no lo
veis pero ya lo digo yo short en 416 vale es decir el mínimo que marca en la primera hora menos 20
puntos en los 20 puntos esto ya os digo yo igual que os dije que que también lo veréis sistemas
de bollinger en ambos lados que lo trabajaremos vale un día pero cuando hagamos a ver ratio
seguramente salimos varios días porque lo haremos en los dos lados del mercado este también es uno
que se puede hacer vale se puede hacer entonces os recomiendo que probéis a ver en qué activos
seguramente en qué activo irá mejor en un activo a más de mí en revertir hablábamos antes de los
tos incluso les de 500 activos un poco más pesados vale más pesados entonces al contrario es decir
el en muchas ocasiones el rango de la primera hora marca una parte importante de la sesión no os
diría tampoco que entraras directamente a vender a comprar en el mínimo y a vender en el máximo o
incluso en este caso a lo mejor en este caso del dax hablo a lo mejor cogería el rango desde todo
el día que ha hecho toda la noche hasta las 8 9 le puedes dar un poco más de margen y a partir de
ahí sí que compra en el mínimo de ese rango es decir lo contrario que estamos haciendo ahora no
no operar la ruptura sino operar la reversión lógicamente con esto y ya está y ya veréis que
varios activos estos va a ir bien contrariamente a lo que estamos haciendo lo contrario pero eso
a veces lo que os digo siempre explorar las ideas al revés de lo que lo que os dice vale ser valientes
en sentido explorar las ideas al revés porque muchas veces el revés van bien también en algunos
casos y este es uno de ellos es uno de ellos donde la pauta de reversión de la primera hora a
mejor extendiéndola un poco en el premarket pero suele suele ver bien suele ver bien vale pero
insisto que ahora no estamos haciendo eso ahora estamos viendo la reversión la reversión perdón
la break out open range break out marcado por el rango de la primera hora vale esto se podría
haber implementado de varias maneras que aún mal lo ha hecho así porque lo ha hecho así porque
él sale con una regla del diario que nosotros en principio no bueno en el código hemos implementado
la opción de usarla o no pero él sale a través de ahora lo miramos de una tr calcula y está para
eso esa media sabe la diaria está para calcular la tr y el de 10 minutos es porque vende ahí o sea
en este en este caso porque quiere operar cada más rápido en 10 minutos ahora ahora el fija el
rango en el de la hora pero luego a partir de que acaba la primera vela de la hora partir ya
en cada 10 minutos podría vender aquí vende en este caso en la primera vela de acuerdo a las 9 y
10 y ha vendido de acuerdo es decir fija el rango hasta las 9 y a las 9 es lo rompe se pone corto y
pues no le da muy buenos resultados sí que es verdad que parece la sesión marcada y un poquito
perfil no se queda rápidamente lateral aquí su mecanismo de salida no cierra fin de día en nosotros
sí pero aquí en su código original que ya explica que está lo publicó la revista esto
con commodities en julio del 94 por cierto una revista a la que recomiendo suscribirse
pues bueno él opera como veis bueno como veis espérate
esto es el indicador es una estrategia esto es esto tcm is trading system and methods es el
las siglas de las siglas del libro en inglés todo lo que empieza por tcm es un libro para que te veas
aquí esto que creo tengo algunas otras versiones que a verdad que no recuerdo yo creo que deben
ser del curso porque como muchos cursos de programación y demás yo creo que es de algún
alumno de alguna pieza por dólar y creo que es lo que hacíamos en algún mejor algún
alumno de ejercicios para casa o algo no pero bueno lo original es este que empieza por
portes de protés en vale aquí ya te ponen las instrucciones y lo que os decía simplemente vende
en la pérdida cuando el cierre de la barra anterior pie es menor que el valor que ha guardado como
máximo o mínimo de relación en el caso de comprar el máximo más el filtro en el caso de vender el
mínimo menos el filtro que lo fija fijo en 20 puntos es un tanto absurdo porque hablan activos
que 20 puntos será mucho 20 pocos la verdad que ahora mismo no recuerdo no sé si abierto se
acordará en qué activo él lo puso original pero el workspace lo tenemos por ahí no creo si
a ver que lo voy a abrir lo voy a abrir el workspace más que nada para ver en qué lo ideó él sabes
porque así lo lo voy a abrir el workspace suyo el workspace suyo original así veremos para qué
activo lo lo pensó lo diseñó lo que fuera no esto debe estar por aquí el capítulo 16 era creo
pues no está los países aquí no está los países aquí a coño pues no sé por qué yo
pensaba que había workspace vaya hombre mira de paso estoy viendo si tengo el código suyo
tocado que lo tengo que lo voy a dejar original vale el suyo a no no puedo no puedo claro no puedo
no puedo que entonces no me va de pasar que yo vale vale pues no sé por qué yo pensaba que
teníamos pues bueno pues es igual no no lo sé que tenía que mirar el libro ahora un momento
no vamos a perder el tiempo en cual lo tenía lo tenía puesto pero bueno no sé cuál habrán 20
puntos que serán de todas maneras desde el 90 y pico pues habrá cambiado mucho la cosa pero
que tendrán unos sentidos y nosotros entonces lo normal en estos casos es hacerlo con un input y
como ya os he dicho hasta la saciedad del curso mejor en porcentaje de acuerdo mejor en porcentaje
porque así escala si escala si no no escala y no tiene nada que ver 20 puntos con el tax a 14
mil que con el tax a 5000 entonces no es lo mismo así que es mejor escalarlo vale pero ya digo así
es como era original en cuanto a la salida fijaros que él fija un average day range que
calcula con el data 3 lo que os decía ves hace la media del high menos el low tn periodos eso
es un true range no sé por qué no sé no perdón no es un true range es un range es un range no sé
por qué lo calcula así porque eso existe de acuerdo pero bueno igual no existía en tiempo
porque lo mismo que estas funciones son antiguas decir pues bueno como todo es evolucionado a
mejor no no serán pero esto es lo mismo que hacer es lo mismo que hacer a ver a ver a ver a ver el
doble price el price sería range y el periodo pues sería lo mismo que hacer esto pero para ser
exactos habría que poner range of data 3 hay que hacer esto vale pero bueno que es igual esto no
se pedí con los casos de programación esto pero ya para que lo que lo que lo haga que no se vuelva
lo que vale sería lo mismo que hacer esto vale haber a range of data 3 que es el high menos low
del lente ya está calcula y ya está y si más lo guarda y de ahí cuando el mínimo pierde el máximo
que ha guardado también el ser sion first bar hike que es el máximo que ha hecho en los 60 minutos
de acuerdo es decir es el máximo que guarda en la apertura es decir ese máximo que guarda para entrar
claro es que también es el mismo la misma variable que usa para entrar vale para entrar largo en este
caso para entrar corto ha usado session first low porque ha perdido corto menos 20 minutos 20 puntos
pues para salir del corto no usa el mínimo sino el máximo de acuerdo usa el máximo y le quita le
quita el el rango de la vela de sesión le quita o sea le quita la laboratividad y sale al mercado
cuando él pierde ese mínimo vale muchas veces eso no ocurre como pasa aquí y por lo tanto se
queda se queda se queda se queda hasta que incluso valdia al día contrario aquí pasa por ejemplo se
va bastante a la contra y sale pero pero vaya a la contra no perdón a favor a favor no quiero
es que es un sistema como os digo que no es ni me está completo recuerdo está completo porque
tiene una salida que si os fijáis es más un tp es más un tp que un una salida en esto pues
decir en esto pues no no sé si aquí hay casos graves pero es una salida que no alguno hay no
alguno alguno hay alguno hay vez acabas saliendo porque al día siguiente recalcula rangos de
acuerdo y por lo tanto vuelve a entrar en el otro lado puede entrar en otro lado se va muy
a la contra vale pero durante la sesión ya digo por ir muy a la contra es no se sale es más tp que
otra cosa vale es más tp que otra cosa entonces al final de hecho hay algunos la misma sesión no
es que quiero ver uno que haga tp la sesión este por ejemplo es este por ejemplo para para
ahí vas pues entra en ruptura y al final hace tp es lo que os decía la salida es un tp porque
fijaros que calcula del mínimo vale o sea del máximo le resta un valor le resta un valor del
rango lo cual lo aleja entonces al final es un es más bien un tp es más bien un tp que son
estas líneas que veis aquí la entrada es esta línea punteada menos 20 puntos la salida es la
rosa o la contraria que es azul el tema que está un poco medias el mismo en el texto lo dice no
recomendable por el un stop y tal o salir a fin de día etcétera no es otra la cosa que decidimos
en una entraría si queremos una entraría puro me refiero al salir o no fin de día lo normal es
salir a fin de día vale pero es verdad que no es obligatorio entra un poco lo que os decía antes
de que tengo yo y que quiero vale y también depende mucho de cuenta al principio este tipo
de sistemas son los muy operados empezamos con uno la otra vez más de largo plazo y ahora empezamos
uno con más de entraría vale este tipo de sistemas por aplastante mayoría es el primero
que elegiría es la mayoría de vosotros para empezar a operar tipo de este por qué porque
y cerrando fin de día y con esto porque porque al final te permite te permite tener seguramente
de rodones un poco más bajos bueno el dax quizá no pero pero bueno no podemos operar en un futuro
un poquito más pequeño en un activo que no se mueva tanto no por ejemplo el spy el cú cú etcétera
pero a el minidax el micro pero realmente son sistemas que son más manejables y que
normalmente conseguiremos drawdowns más bajos y por lo tanto poderlos operar con una cuenta
más pequeña porque requeriremos menos garantías para operarlos vale cambio sistema que va gráfico
diario semanal pues es más complicado por lo tanto la primera elección de un sistema es probable
que sea un intradiario de acuerdo por qué primero porque tenemos la sensación de poder controlar el
riesgo mejor y después porque es verdad es verdad que al no asumir el riesgo gab si yo quiero cerrar
a fin de día pues voy a poder controlar mejor ese riesgo bien no eso es otro sistema que tenemos
ahí de gaps que ya lo haremos bien vamos ahora a meterle la los cambios que hemos que hemos hecho
que veréis ahí que tiene muchos inputs pero nuevamente son de configuración y no tienen
porque usarse hemos dejado su mecanismo por si lo queremos usar vale pero hemos implementado
algunos cambios bastante parecidos a los que ya habíamos visto la otra vez algunos de ellos
el código es es el mismo pero hemos introducido como input el porcentaje para confirmar la entrada
en tanto por cien en este caso no por puntos sino en un porcentaje si es cero pues no cero de acuerdo
y si es un porcentaje pues el que sea hemos incorporado un porcentaje de esto y un porcentaje
de profit en tanto por cien que si es cero no actúa vale esta es una manera siempre
y recomendable de programar es decir haciendo con con variables tipo switch no que al final si yo
le pongo si tal es mayor que cero con eso estoy usando un switch de acuerdo ahora llegaría
aquí vale si el porcentaje esto es mayor que cero si no pues no entra de acuerdo esto es bastante
bastante habitual de una manera fácil y sencilla de pues configurar los sistemas con muchos inputs
pero que no tienes porque usarlos es al final para hacer pruebas y poder probar distintas cosas como
como ese módulo que comentaba alguien no recuerdo si os lo daríamos que sí pues para probar
distintas entradas distintas salidas sobre el mismo código pues meter varios módulos de entrar
y de salir y automáticamente meterlo a sistema para probar de hecho el mismo tres station permite
hacer eso es decir yo aquí recordar aquellos que no estés familiarizados que yo puedo añadir
los sistemas de manera modular entre eso puedo poner la entrada y la salida la puedo poner suelta
puedo poner salida por tp salida por esto salida tal salida tal tal y meter las sueltas ir poniendo
una quitándola y independiente de la entrada vale esto es bastante práctico para probar cosas en
tres station de hecho no bien volvemos al inicio del código también tenemos la salida original
con un 0 1 es decir cero no actúa uno usa la salida original que era esa que habéis visto que
no deja de ser un tp tp lo que ahora nos recuerda alberto si le hemos puesto que si va esa no van
al resto no puede son complementarias son complementarias son complementarias si si si
ahora mientras se lo preguntaba me lo me ha venido vale número de cierres al final de días es decir
si yo quiero cerrar a fin de día es uno si quiero cerrar en dos días obviamente si no sale por otro
motivo puedo tener esto tp y salida fin de día vale puedo salir a n días es decir obligatoriamente
te sales a un día obligatoriamente te sales a dos te sales a tres insisto si no te has salido por
otro motivo luego también trades máximos permitidos en el mismo día esto también es
bastante habitual y recomendable en los sistemas intradiarios de acuerdo es meter un input meter
una mecanismo en el código que cuente el número de trades que hacemos y que si tú haces n 1 2 3
los que sean no puede hacer más de acuerdo también aunque en este no hemos implementado
esta es recomendable como siempre meter la posibilidad de ir largo ir corto o ir a los
dos lados esto es ya un poquito casi en todos los sistemas es recomendable hacerlo y se suele se
suele hacer bien y luego hemos metido al ver este paper que habéis aportado pues hemos decidido
probarlo de acuerdo hemos decidido probarlo en el tax no tiene mucho sentido pero pero si en el
ya lo diría en acciones en acciones si nos da tiempo lo veremos un un momentito lo veremos un
momentito vale bueno esto ya lo había dicho antes o que se decía vale puedo centrar en
objetivos y límites de pérdida y cerrar beneficios sobre los más todos el rv de par burritos
digamos no el rv mega básico vale ya hemos visto un poco más que eso y todo el paper el paper
déjame que os lo enseñe bueno el paper ya os lo he puesto ahí en castellano lo ha hecho alberto
con la inestimable ayuda de chat gpt versión 4 y al final tenía unos tenía unos filtros
simplemente hemos aportado los filtros no hemos hecho el sistema al uso que creo no sé si se
me había comentado que lo había hecho se puede perfectamente hacer hay muchas versiones de este
más y yo he probado esta que es la mega básica la mega estándar hay muchas más y ya os digo que
veremos más cosas más cosas veremos evolucionar este veremos otros completamente distintos pero
bueno que este como habéis puesto ya el paper yo quería partir de este del cajón porque me
interesa mucho introducir este concepto de open break out que es el original podemos decir no el
habéis oído uno rb es esto de acuerdo rb clásico como todo permite un montón de variaciones que
hemos visto el porcentaje de esto por un taje de profit podía ser por la tr la entrada podía
ser exigirle un movimiento de volatilidad en intradías también se me ha olvidado comentaros
una cosa antes es verdad que lo habitual lo habitual en intradía es sistemas que operan mucho
que operan mucho y que por lo tanto tienen mucha significación estadística pero también hay algunos
intradía que no os lo recomiendo como primera opción pero que sí que como complemento de una
cartera pueden venir muy bien vale si este más de muy poca actuación me parece que el uno de los
dos uno de los dos documentos intradía que os he pasado lo explicaba no me acuerdo ahora no lo
veo aquí bueno digamos son tres temas de muy poca frecuencia operativa es decir que buscan
sucesos de elevadísima probabilidad de protagés de protagé de acierto muy elevado creo que se
ocurre en poco que ocurre en poco pero que tienen protagé de acierto muy muy alto aún así cuidado
hay que validarlo y todo como siempre pero ahí estamos a una mejor de un número de tres tipo
diario sabes tipo sema diario aunque tienes un montón de barras y analizadas realmente operan
una vez al mejor al mes o sabes decir cosas que o mirando analizando el gráfico intradía pero
que pasa muy pocas veces pautas de velas que os decía este tipo de pautas que os decía
hay varios veremos alguna veremos alguna ahora mismo no me acuerdo que lo diga porque ahora mismo
no me acuerdo sé que habíamos visto alguno en el pasado nos dos ahora mismo no operamos ninguno de
este tipo pero es probable que lo que lo que lo vamos a saber esto no sé historia de los futuros
y demás no podamos volver a los futuros casi con total seguridad que lo que los operaremos y
entonces pues los explorar y analizar con calma porque hace mucho tiempo que no los que nos miró
pero sí que los hay son normalmente figuras ya os digo de bautas de velas cuando me refiero de
velas quiero decir de precio como os decía una inside bar pues de dobles y triples y muchos de
volatilidad es decir de recuerdo tenía uno que era de volatilidad pero de rango bestial es decir
era un poco parecido a esto que habéis visto ahora de más cero más un filtro era un filtro
enorme vale era un filtro enorme que pero que tenían protege de acento más grandes y cuando
el mercado tiene desviaciones de más de x x desviaciones en la media casi siempre casi
lógicamente quiere decir que no siempre cada y siempre marca un movimiento es decir no no llega
a partir de lo que no vuelve o que hay alguna que vuelve pero la mayoría no vuelve cuando
desvía de desvía de la volatilidad un cierto número normalmente indica el inicio de un
movimiento y esto es una pauta de las más sólidas que existe lo que pasa que como os digo tiene una
frecuencia operativa relativamente baja tiene una frecuencia operativa relativamente bajo por eso
van bien en una cartera como complemento porque diversifican pero como operativa principal pues
es un sistema que entre que tiene poca significación estadística y que tampoco de media va a dar mucho
dinero porque opera poco al cual el final se llama que opera poco pues lógicamente pues se puede dar
menos menos dinero entonces lo que os decía la los filtros que tenía implementado el paper y
básicamente eran dos donde están el filtro básico vale que simplemente era para filtrar este
era un filtro prácticamente de filtrar el universo de acciones más bien para escupir un poco los
chicharros pinches y acciones de poca de poco volumen y demás no porque al final ellos han
detectado que como el criterio tuvimos este debate en el anterior sistema que dijo bueno
por qué operar las demás capitalización o más volumen bueno porque normalmente donde funcionan
mejor las figuras no es técnico son en esas y también en las contrarias en las contrarias
no es que funcione mejor las técnicas funciona mejor lo que ocurre es que en las de muy poca
volatilidad en las de muy poco precio poco volumen y demás ocurre el efecto contrario que cuando
tienen volumen pues provoca movimientos brutales entonces sí que es verdad que gente como los
nitreres que se dedican específicamente específicamente a ello no bueno puede que
tratemos de abordar algún sistema de ese tipo de acuerdo que son por lo que os decía poco son
sistemas de poca frecuencia operativa en cada activo pero que al final buscan operar en muchas
acciones en muchas acciones pero ya digo explotando volatilidad es auténticamente salvajes no pero en
este caso es el paper lo que hacía es esquivar esas acciones no buscaba acciones que cerrarán
por encima de 5 porque 5 esto seguramente es algún tipo de optimización implícita que el volumen
medio pues sea mayor que x vale en este caso lo tenía fijado en un millón y que la verá
su rent también sea mayor de 0 5 porque 0 5 bueno pues por lo que os digo seguramente un tipo
de optimización implícita este era un filtro y el otro sí que era un filtro más de operativa
podemos decir donde buscaba que el volumen que lo guardábamos aquí porque era el volumen del data
2 de 60 minutos el mismo donde habíamos guardado el range ese rango de la primera la primera hora
pues en ese momento en el momento en que identificamos esa primera hora guardamos el máximo
guardamos el mínimo guardamos la fecha y guardamos el volumen de acuerdo y usando ese volumen para
compararlo con la media del volumen de las otras 14 ocurrencias que en este caso es de los otros
14 días porque esta vela sólo se mide una al día por lo tanto es la media de 14 días esto se
entiende y este era el otro el otro filtro relativo que utilizaba bueno este podría tener algún
sentido aquí podemos probarlo hemos probado un poco no parecía ir muy especialmente bien aquí
pero bueno es verdad que el volumen tiene más sentido en acciones que en futuros también puede
pero donde tiene mayores sentidos en la acción no en la acción porque el futuro al final no deja
de ser aunque también puedes ir corto en acciones es muy residual comparativamente con lo que es
ir largo en cambio en un futuro indistintamente puedes ir largo ir corto el volumen es simétrico
en acciones no en acciones al final hay que repositar un dinero por tanto el volumen sólo
tiene un lado entonces más tiene una señal un poco más limpia podemos decir un poquito más
pero no quiere decir que no se puede usar de hecho se usa y también se usa más el open
interés quizá en futuros el volumen el volumen de acciones es más el open interés en futuros
se me entienda no es que sea lo mismo pero técnicamente quiero decir es más no porque
al final lo pero interés sí que identifica los que se quedan abiertos al final de día
lo que pasa que es una lectura un poco retrasada no pero pero hay que mirar la fin de día pero
pero pero se obtiene las maneras de plataformas se da todo lo tienen bien bueno pues nada más el
sistema en sí es lo mismo a nivel de entrada con esa característica que os fijáis que el rango de
apertura de ocho a nueve es esta vela que acaba a las nueve una vela pequeñita esto aquí también
podría haberse hecho algún filtro de este tipo es decir que si esta vela no es de un cierto rango
puedes no entrar se podría hacer algo así pero esto no necesariamente es malo recordar lo que os
decía el range breakout no al final de cuando el mercado está colapsado y de hecho aquí lo
hace vez el mercado está con poca volatilidad y colapsa no colapsa pero lo hace a la baja lo hace la
baja vale entonces aquí de momento lo tenemos configurado con cero con la salida original en
cero con solo cerrando a fin de día con un trade por día vamos a dejarle tres por día
sin filtro básico en el filtro relativo esta monetaria de momento no estamos dándole muchas
vueltas a esto 100% de la cuenta y hasta el dinero disponible y ya está de configuración
004 nuestro pues no me acuerdo es un poco hemos hecho una pequeña optimización nos ha salido
valores de este tipo y bueno pues ahí queda en este caso pues como veis acaba saliendo por
esto los acabas haciendo por esto los y así hemos hecho pequeñas pruebas no iba para alguna
versión que hemos hecho no había ido mal en el tax el todo pero no en esta que está puesta aquí
creo que va bastante bastante flojo pero bueno sí que seguramente se podría extraer algo se
podría extraer algo de esta de esta idea aunque seguramente dándole un poco más de margen a la
entrada y seguramente a lo mejor ajustándolo más bien por volatilidad seguramente hay que ajustarlo
por volatilidad y también aunque esta vez no lo hemos implementado puede ser recomendable salir
por tiempo suele ir muy bien esta salida también ya como se comentaba y luego habría que en este
caso la salida por tiempo iría un poco ligado con lo que os decía antes de la ventana operativa
vale el dax si si metemos aquí el volumen veréis que tiene una pauta estudiar estudiar el volumen es
muy interesante vale no sólo por el tema de que haya liquidez o no de acuerdo es por lo que os decía
de esta relación absolutamente clara entre el volumen y la volatilidad de acuerdo entonces
una manera indirecta de usar esto es meter volumen meter una media por defecto sale de 50 vale pues
bueno pues usar esa y ver un poquito cómo va cómo va evolucionando el volumen hay el dax normalmente
en europa el volumen va es bastante estable lógicamente es asor aquí ya no estamos cargando
todo lo voy a cargar ahora sólo porque lo veáis vale que nos da un poco nos da un poco igual porque
esto no es nada descabellado es decir otro camino otro camino que sería no lo he probado pero alguien
nuevamente igual que os decía antes de probar esto también os os recomiendo probar el que os
digo ahora que es hacer range breakout igual cargar todo el histórico hablando del dax en este caso y
definirlo igual pero incorporando también los datos de esta una de la mañana a ocho de la mañana
es decir como si todo esto fuera la barra de apertura de acuerdo muchos operadores en eeuu hacen
esto es decir hacen el open range breakout incluyendo el premarket de acuerdo incluyendo el
premarket tengo dudas no no lo he probado es lo digo francamente lo estoy ahora pensando decir
tengo dudas de si desde la una a la mejor incorporar también la 7 o la 6 o incorporar o hacerlo de 8
a 9 y dejar hasta las 10 entendéis es decir o abrir a las 9 meterlo de 9 a 10 es decir todas
estas combinaciones son válidas porque porque el volumen realmente habría que ver si este volumen
que es es ruido absoluto es decir todo este todo este para cargar también aquí todo esto es ruido
totalmente es decir el problema es que yo este ahora no lo cargo este no lo voy a cargar porque
si lo cargo me va a calcular recordar que el rango lo calcula de esta me lo va a calcular de la primera
y es un churro es decir lo que va a salir ahí no va a tener ningún tipo de sentido valendo es pero
se me entienda no es decir los he cargado aquí en el de arriba para que de 10 minutos veáis un
poco todo todo esto no yo podría al mejor usar también este rango es decir que en vez de fijar
solo la primera vela está vale además estuviera contando desde este mínimo para que entendáis
no es que este día tenga nada especial sino para que tendáis contar este mínimo y el máximo que
haya hecho hasta hasta aquí que sería este por decir el range break out sería en este caso este
vale ese sería aquí se hubiera puesto corto bastante más tarde lo cual peor vale bien y lo
que os decía del volumen es que evidentemente está de 1 a 2 que es muy importante estudiar como
decía volumen y volatilidad que van de la misma mano y horario que no va no es de la misma cara
pero tiene bastante que ver con esto para analizar en qué ventanas yo no me interesa es decir hay
dos maneras a filtrar vale el filtro que siempre se usa más y más intuitivo es filtrar las entradas
de acuerdo es filtrar las entradas es decir yo voy a maximizar mis probabilidades no voy a
haber ventajas más buenas como hago eso pues decir bueno pues antes hablaba no decir pues voy
a operar solo cuando haya una volatilidad determinada de acuerdo voy a operar solo cuando
haya un volumen determinado vale o voy a operar solo cuando la estructura de precios no lo que
no cuando haya solo una situación que me hable de un mercado en congestión porque yo busco
expansión y sé que normalmente tras una congestión ver una expansión entonces cuando vea que haya un
poco a volatilidad o cuando vea que haya una insight para lo que os decía antes no con el diario
respecto al anterior cosas así no puedo buscar operativas de este tipo para filtrar entradas
cuando hablo de filtrar salidas que hago bueno pues donde si yo considero que hay momentos donde el
mercado se mueve poco pues yo puedo salirme de acuerdo puedo ya salirme porque considero que si
el mercado no ha ido a mi favor en ese caso no normal es que ya no vaya tendéis ese sería un
poco la idea esto donde es el dax por el dax no es claro porque el dax tiene como dos ventanas
tiene tres ventanas operativas de europa europa tiene una apertura bastante movida vale tiene
una apertura con mucho movimiento que a veces dura hasta las 10 a veces dura solo unos minutos
pero normalmente es esa ese rango que va hasta las 10 o por ahí suele haber bastante movimiento a
ver si veo una sesión típica bueno esto es bastante típico a nivel de pauta de volumen vale veis a
las 8 puede ya haber un incremento de volumen que aquí parece que no es tanto pero es bastante
se queda anulado por el por el el de las nueve que es el grande porque es el grande porque
entra el contado vale una guía que te suele ir muy bien también es esto vale en la relación
con el contado en eeuu pasa igual cuando no está el contado pues no porque al final estos son
subyacentes y cuando no está el contado no está nuestra jefe de acuerdo no está el que manda y
entonces al final cuando hay más movimiento siempre es coincidencia con el contado cuando
es esto en europa es de 9 a 5 y media acuerdo en eeuu desde 3 y media a 10 por eso hasta ese
media entra un volumen absolutamente de locos en los futuros americanos porque entra el contado
entra apple entra google entra todo y ahí entra todo el volumen y es donde de verdad se mueve
normalmente cuando hay noticias dos y media se mueve mucho pero realmente de esa últimos 15
minutos media hora del mercado está bastante ya tranquilo bueno 1 o 2 minutos antes ya a
veces se empieza a agitar pero empieza a y media y se dispara bueno pues aquí pasa un poquito igual
este es un día que voy a acercar para que veas muy muy paradigmático no en el sentido que viene
el mercado muerto desde la una bueno se levanta un poquito pero está todo el rato ahí plano no
no hay volumen no hay volumen abajo vale plan plan plan plan llega a las 8 fijaros que el volumen
empieza a saltar pero el precio no precio poco el volumen ya y ves 8 y 10 fijaros la primera
vez las 7 50 estamos hablando ahí de 197 contratos y ha empezado a moverse realmente 7 8 es
proporcional a las 8 8 y 5 8 de suele haber un pico porque porque porque ahí se abren los bonos
vale y también abre londres vale entonces ahí solemos tener ese ese el bono el bono inglés
entonces ahí hay una referencia importante las divisas se animan más entonces a las 8 y veces que
ya se anima un poco pero realmente es a las 9 donde entra entre la talla y hay veces que a
las 10 se ha acabado la sesión es así de triste es que a las 10 se ha acabado el mercado ya está
adiós y hay operadores que hacen eso operadores que operan un range breakout pero muy justo más
cerrado que esto no buscar a lo mejor la hora sino ir en un minuto en 2 en 5 minutos y a las
10 se acaba la sesión operan de 8 a 10 si hay movimiento bien si no hay movimiento hasta mañana
en el dax no quieren ya porque porque es muy habitual que de 10 hasta las noticias el mercado
esté plano y con poco volumen decreciente que no es que tampoco bueno pero fíjate o sea aquí te
mete saberás que en eeuu también baja pero no así de acuerdo luego viene la hora de las
noticias que cuando hay noticias ya se anima y lógicamente viene vuelos y lo levanta y lo levanta
y ahí empieza otra sesión hasta las 5 que muere 5 5 y media a veces 5 45 muere completamente va hasta
las 10 con el mercado americano pero no ser que el mercado americano tire mucho que lógicamente
lo sigue el mercado también se queda muerto desde que tampoco suele rentar hasta el final en
este tipo de estrategias tú vas en swing esto es otra historia pero tú buscar a este tipo
de estrategias entraría buscas probabilidad buscas cierto buscas movimiento breakout volatilidad
entonces este ejemplo que pisa aquí es el típico operativa buena de breakout a pillo y para casa y
por lo tanto muchas veces puede tener sentido salir porque no porque el precio ha ido mi contra
porque haya hecho te peoró imaginaros un día que no he hecho te peoró y ya está ya es que ya está
vendido 10 no sé 11 pues fuera a las 11 me salvo esté como esté y hasta mañana o si el cierro esa
puedo tener pero yo lo evaluaría con otro sistema esto lo explicó un gere en el año que ganó
ganado varios que se presentó al campeonato del mundo que la primera vez que lo ganó creo que
fue lo ganó operando sólo el euro dólar pero con sistemas en ventanas distintas es esto que os estoy
diciendo exactamente es decir un sistema preparado que va de 8 a 10 otro que va de 10 a 12 otro que
va de 12 a 2 porque porque las divisas tienen pautas temporales muy establecidas por cierto
me acabo de acabar creo que esa más rugat apúntamelo alberto por favor que le debo el
forex estrés y me lo pidió me acabo de acordar ahora me acabo de acordar aurel y quiero que eras
tú perdóname me acabo de acordar pues en ese te voy a enviar te voy a enviar lo original que
tiene tres station que es muy antiguo pero pero ahí hay unos indicadores que sirve para medir el
tiempo espero que funcione porque son muy antiguos y y está está para analizar esto las pautas
horarias y tal entonces ahí ya te digo ahí hay muchas estrategias que usan esto porque
porque a lo mejor en unas horas opera breakout en otras es más tendencial al lateral y entonces
operar reversión me explico entonces si tú sabes que estadísticamente lógicamente no va a ser cada
día hay activos que normalmente los tirones el mínimo del día esto lo veremos también no sigo
como la teoría diciendo lo veremos pero es que es verdad cuando veamos todo esto como has comentado
antes de distintas pautas veremos varios códigos de este tipo y hay uno que hice un artículo hace
tiempo que lo explicaba hace años que esto es un código que lo la primera vez que lo vi luego lo
he visto en otros pero fue en el libro de cauman que era analizar a qué horas por ejemplo un activo
hace máximos 12 mínimos o cosas así no o los gaps medios de los de los de los activos es decir
sin temas son códigos que sacan información a texto para que luego la puedas trabajar y ver
por ejemplo que cuántos gaps se cierran cuántos tal a partir de que o sea todo esto información que
sacas del histórico de acuerdo entonces esto te permite analizar esto que os digo pues yo sé que
me lo invento que el dax cada vez que el gap es de 0 5 lo cierra el 70 por ciento si es un 70
por ciento es un sistema buenísimo entiendes pues bueno pues yo cuando abre con un 0 5 compro me
entiendes es menos inventado el 0 5 no que nada lo tome que ya lo miraremos de bien que no me acuerdo
como era pero me entendéis o sé que hay activos que el 70 por ciento de sus máximos diarios son
a las dos entre dos y dos y media bueno pues yo sé que entre dos y dos y medio si hay un pivo me
pongo corto entendéis entonces este tipo de cosas pues este tipo de ventanas va muy bien y por eso
os digo que ni entraría es muy habitual usar ventanas entonces aquí por ejemplo en este en este
caso pues a lo mejor podríamos trabajar esto vale yo hago un open range breakout puedo mirar de filtrar
las entradas bien vale y las salidas a lo mejor las filtro de esta manera yo a partir de cierta
hora que ya no me renta porque porque yo sé que la mayoría de máximos o mínimos del dac son antes
de las dos que luego ya así que a última hora tiene uno muchos otra vez también bueno pues un
caso luego a de 8 a 10 a mejor me otro otro sistema y sabes porque si yo sé que ahora mismo no tendría
que mirar bien pero era que sí que yo sé que entre las cinco y media 45 ahí suele marcar un
mínimo máximo que normalmente me sirve de rango entonces yo ahí ya automáticamente dejo eso como
máxima la sesión y si lo vuelvo a visitar vendo ahí yo vendo yo de 6 a 10 de la noche o pero un
un mil reversión comprando y vendiendo a lo mejor vendo compro cinco veces en cinco minutos
un día el rango va me saco pues nada mejor diez puntos pero oye son de mucha probabilidad porque
sé que eso pasa casi siempre por ejemplo no y pues ya digo en las sesiones hay muchas pautas
estacionales de acuerdo es decir hay comportamientos bastante recurrentes y analizarlos
mediante código y demás es muy interesante que como digo ya lo haremos durante algún día estos
y nos permitirá sacar estrategias sacar información para montar estrategias que son sencillas que no
dejan de ser breakouts que no dejan de ser mil reversión cosas así pero que están basadas en
simplemente el comportamiento natural que tiene el activo en una sesión también las materias primas
se da mucho también las materias primas se da mucho las materias primas también se dan a nivel
mensual que tienen que ver con la cosecha el gasolio de calefacción pues seré pautas que
dependen del ciclo del calor del frío de determinados países final hemisferios al final
hay el petróleo pues también inventarios etcétera no hay muchos factores que lógicamente no hay
nada que hay funciones siempre pero al final buscamos poner probabilidades a nuestro a nuestro
favor no bien entonces aquí teníamos este sencillos estimeta que ahora mismo no sé cómo lo tenía
cuánto histórico tengo cargado espérate voy a cargar esto como estaba y mientras vamos a ver el
de acciones voy a dejar aquí una optimización puesta 10 minutitos breve que me va a hacer el
trabajo creo aunque no sé me da un poco de miedo estoy pensando casi que no lo voy a hacer hemos
guardado alguna al final pero tú creo que no no así guardado una yo creo no no me acuerdo espérate
que lo miro hemos guardado de acciones no sé si es que se me ha colgado el hecho una aquí que
estaba guapa que la he analizado pero se me ha colgado porque cuando se cuelga cuando abres
multichars antes de abrir abierto 3d son a veces el access se cuelga porque multichar se alimenta
de 3d son de datos entonces depende como cuáles abres antes a veces lo se instabiliza 3d entonces
se me ha colgado y no lo he podido guardar entonces pues nada no no no tengo guardados
de multichar de lo de acciones pero de no no no no no no no no apuntado bueno es igual ya lo ya lo
ya lo miraremos pero era era era parecida es que ésta era una de ellas a que está puesta era una
de ellas las maneras ahora he guardado espérate si si he hecho esa todo lo que pasa es que me
da miedo meter el procesador porque el multichar no puede regular aquí no puedo me da miedo meter
el procesador al 100% estando en directo tienes no pero montar ese son no aquí pero me vas a
rediciar a tienes razón lo puedo trucar pues mira lo voy a hacer va vamos a hacerlo lo voy a
hacer lo voy a hacer lo voy a hacer lo voy a hacer y a ver si le pongo la mitad no a ver
compatibility no autoconfigure no a ti que un fútbol de tampoco me te vete a no justo
que no me ha acordado aquí a ver 8 para el modo todo ocho y ya está bien todo ocho
y si yo me he dicho que yo voy a gusto usted se va a esperar ahora lo creo es que lo que me da
miedo es que no quedamos atrás no tengo que cerrar multichar no tengo que cerrar este el
guardo no sé el mundo lo tengo que cerrar porque si no lo no me lo va a abrir y además de hecho
me voy a asegurar que se ha cerrado todo es ahí lo tienes pero tienes ahí lo tienes abierto y no
abierto no me nada abierto no bueno sabe por por todo el trato espérate espérate lo va a
insultar ya no guardó aquí lo va a insultar ya tenía por favor traer abierto con lo cual era
eso que lo que lo tenía abierto vale pues no está a ver si ahora se cierra bien se ha cerrado
sacado sacado sacado sacado pues no estaba colgado estaba estaba de paula irá vamos a ver que no se
vea la contraseña que tendría que matarlos a todos, no es plan ahora, ahora va a abrir un
poco más lento pero lo normal es que no me bloquee el equipo al optimizar, pues creo que no, ¿por?
No, sí, ahora ya lo había guardado, ¿a qué te refieres? No, no, esto ya estaba, esto ya estaba,
esto ya estaba, sí, sí, esto ya estaba, claro, esto ya estaba, que bueno, lo voy a mirar pero
yo creo que ya está, esto está, Eurex, todo bien, todo bien, todo bien, de hecho igual ahora,
igual ahora, mira, no, digo, a ver si está la optimización al abrir, no, no, no, no había,
no había, no había, además tengo activo el otro, tengo activo el otro, vale, ahora le vamos a dar
un poco, candela, vamos a dar candela, aquí nada, estoy pensando que le podíamos dejar de TP su
salida, tío, vamos a probar, mira, me gusta esa propiedad, va, venga, pues a mí sí, vamos,
esta como era, como la hemos hecho antes, bueno, la que tengo aquí, no, bueno, hemos hecho de darle
un poco más, eh, por probar, a ver, voy a hacer genética, pues yo sí, le voy a dejar solo el stop,
que tanto no hace falta, que es locura, esta la dejo en cero y le activo su salida y ya está,
que se optimizo menos, de tres le voy a dejar tres, va, cierra a fin de día, sin filtros, venga,
vámonos, tres mil, va, esto nada, esto en genética, lo dejo todo por defecto, venga, a ver,
a ver, me interesa ver cómo va el procesador, venga, aguanta, pues será cinco años supongo,
no, pero si son 50, esto en cuanto empiece, lo que le va a costar es cargar los datos,
luego empiezan a un misil, bueno, no lo sé, lo que pasa es que le he bajado mucho, pero está
a 30 procesadores, aguantando bien, nada, nada, ahí va, 50% procesador, nada, nada, nada, sobrado,
sobrado, le podría haber dado más, venga, aguanta ahí, aguanta ahí, 56, ahí 70%, 70% procesador,
bueno, pues aguanta ahí, aguanta ahí, mientras no sature mucho, 40%, aguantará, yo creo que
aguantaría, porque el go to meeting este es un cohete, sí, ha acabado los narices, para
la primera, gemito, tira, tira, no, lo que pasa es que ya sabes que va acelerando, eso es
policial, ahora nada, en un minuto, mira, dice que un minuto va a tardar segundos, ahí está, ahí va,
90% era CPU, venga, pero bueno, aguanta bien, aguanta bien, mientras no se quede 100% bloqueada,
y la NVIDIA al 23, podía usar más la NVIDIA, coño, no la NVIDIA, sino la tarjeta NVIDIA,
esta NVIDIA no está de cuanto debe valer y alberto, podíamos hacer un trade con las
tarjetas gráficas, porque esto, lo que está subiendo NVIDIA igual nos pagan bien y todo,
ahí está, venga, nada, todo bien, se ha salvado el directo y todo bien, ahora tenemos aquí el
informito, datos bajos de TSI, antes eran más altos, ah, por el TPE, va mucho mejor con el TPE
directo suyo, pero bueno, respetar un poco al autor, hombre, respetar al autor,
bueno, aquí parece que equilibra un poco, ¿no? equilibra un poco entre todos, aquí lo que buscamos
siempre es equilibro, esto lo hacemos en el Excel, pero aquí de mancha pusera buscamos poco equilibrio
entre los tres, ves, TSI, que estén altos todos, vale, entonces, el que menos probabilidad entre los
tres sería Expectancy, pero entre PPC y TSI, pues un poquito de equilibrio, ahí estaría un poquito
más, más o menos el equilibrio, ves, es el mejor TSI, tercero mejor de PPC y bien colocado también
en Expectancy, sería esto un poco, 3000 trades, bien, y con 0.10 y 0.01 de entrada, es decir,
casi nada, casi nada, casi quiere, será el 0, eh, porque con 0.01 es 0, porque el 0 no lo veo,
si lo he usado, si, a ver, aquí el gráfico, mira, por el porcentaje de confirmación es totalmente
errático, no tiene ninguna, ninguna dependencia, lo ves ahí, aquí ordena, aquí ahora yo tengo
ordenado por Expectancy, ordeno por PPC, que es bastante parecido a Profit, perdón, y ahora,
por ejemplo, si yo marco esta columna, aquí los que tienen Session, al hacer el gráfico, estoy viendo
por ordenado, abajo, por retorno, y aquí el número de valores de la variable que le he puesto,
este es el mapa que tiene Session, que es lo que os decía, igual, igual ya podía poner uno en 3D,
¿no? también, igual podía, calla, que hace un poco que no lo pruebo, ahora resulta que
selecciono dos variables y se queda conmigo, eh, ahora verás tú, bueno, te ponen las dos rayas,
si, si, esto ya lo sabía, pero digo, ahora verás, me hace un mapa en 3D y me callo, me tengo que comer,
pues espérate, eh, que tiene aquí el grafiquito, espérate, porque lo pruebo, así, los cojones,
no te imaginas, hace esto en 3D, de hecho, eso es 3D, si os fijáis, pasa que, pues, yo creo que puede
mejorar, yo creo que puede mejorar, sí, sí, entonces, por presentaje, ya has visto que no hay,
y este, este, que es el, el stop, pues aquí sí que se nota un sesgo para arriba, ¿no? en un poco
para arriba, bueno, pues nada, este es un poco, una optimización sencilla, dándole tres entradas,
iba mejor con una antes, eh, mira, ves, aquí he entrado, ya he vuelto a salir, ¿no? esto,
nada, esto es muy flojo, esto es muy flojo, 109, tiene comisiones, eh, es flojito, flojito, además,
el outchample está completamente roto, eh, no, no, está, no le he mirado los robundes que él
lo tiene puesto, eh, está negativo el robundes, tiene robundes muy bajos, tiene estos muy altos,
pero con pocos, con pocos traits, pero vamos a hacer una cosa, ahora me quedo con ésta,
vamos a exportar ésta, solo el, bueno, no, es igual, mira, me voy a guardar la imagen,
yo solo quiero ver una cosa rápida, no me tengo, es nadie, ahora, pero no la veía,
la ventana, ¿dónde está la ventana? ahora como tal, tampoco le voy a hacer lo mismo, pero al revés,
¿sabes? le voy a hacer la misma por el otro lado, quiero ver a ver si la muestra está muy sesgada,
que aquí no hemos, no hemos analizado la muestra, habría que haber analizado un poquito la muestra
y ver qué tal, eh, 30-0, le dejamos el 30 por delante para ver, pero esto antes lo hemos hecho
porque, porque ya digo, queríamos ver un poco el sistema, ya el próximo día lo trabajamos,
podemos decir como Dios manda, ¿vale? hoy, hoy era responder preguntas, plantear el sistema,
que lo vierais, lo atendierais y empezar a hablar de las entradías, daros los tres documentos,
por cierto, recordar que tenéis también más papers, que ya no los he leído, pero entiendo que
sean correctos, aquí en el bar había una circulación de papers aquí, cuando iba a la universidad,
en el bar circulaban otras cosas, pero aquí se han circulado papers en el bar, con los papers y un
vídeo de youtube, tú lo sabes, que he preguntado, no lo he visto, eh, Aureli, lo tengo que ver,
no sé qué, me haces un vídeo de Víctor, sé que lo he abierto antes, ya lo sé, pues ahora
luego lo miro, a ver qué me has dejado, aquí hay otros papers a mirar y bueno, pues a ver,
a ver qué, qué tal salen de, qué tal salen de ahí, eh, tenía, eh, tenía que mirar, me voy a dejar aquí abierto,
también quería ver, a ver qué teníamos en esto con commodities, pero miro, o sea había alguna cosita
nueva de, de ORB, pero el próximo día lo, lo miro, bien, solo me han salido 15, bueno, pues, bueno, por
ORB 15, a ver, esto está por fecha, venga, he acabado, entonces, como veis, es una maravilla, es la suscripción, mira,
ahí tienes, era un minuto, eh, voy a decir que no hay ideas, venga, que analizarlo esto y verlo, a ver qué es, ahí
tenéis, un articulito de ORB, en un segundín, mirad todos los que me han salido, cuando es esto,
ahí parece que hay una serie ahí, ¿no?, tres de ahí, mira, veis, esto es lo que os he decido, de las pautas de velas, esto es
muy, muy habitual, claro, sí, se encuentran cositas, esto ya os lo dije, yo os recomiendo mucho, eh,
esto creo que era una serie, me suena, que hubo, ahí está, veis, sí, sí, sí, esto, pues mira, tenemos seis, pues mira,
este lo, bajaré esta serie, eh, la pasaré por CGPT, a ver si me hacer unos resúmenes, y os la paso,
porque no os puedo, como comprenderéis, no os puedo pasar al original, porque no, no está permitido,
entonces ya lo enseño aquí, que no sé si puedo realmente, pero pasaros no puedo, porque, porque lógicamente
no está, no está permitido, entonces, eh, podía caer un pequeño puro, que entenderéis que no, no es plan,
pero bueno, oye, yo hago un documento mío, ¿no?, he hecho que le va a hacer con CGPT, pero no es verdad, eh,
lo que iba era hacerlo yo, eh, y editarlo y crearlo yo, entonces, una cosa creada por mí, creada por mí, la puedo
perfectamente compartir, ¿vale?, eso es lo que, lo que voy a hacer, utilizando esta documentación, yo voy a
crear un artículo propio, que luego os pasaré, ¿vale?, pero esto es interesante, ¿vale?, esto ya ha acabado, vamos a verlo,
a ver, a ver lo de arriba que me ha salido, antes hemos elegido 0010, a ver dónde está este ahora,
es este, el que hemos elegido antes es este, pero sigue dando mal, mal rebundes, eh, sigue colocando
bien en old data, porque lógicamente el old data es el mismo, pero sigue dando rebundes, rebundes
bajos, aunque han mejorado los rebundes en general, en general han mejorado, y este mismo, este mismo
ha mejorado mucho, claro, antes era negativo, ahora es algo positivo, ¿me estáis hablando a mí?, no, no,
bueno, veremos un poquito, como os decía, el próximo, el próximo día, ese es el que nos, lo voy a dejar
guardado con este, para tener una referencia, pero sí que parece lo que, lo que decía Alberto, mira,
déjame, que me voy a, me voy a quedar, porque antes le había puesto solo uno, ahora le voy a dejar que haga, mira,
vamos a hacer otra cosa, porque como esto, como eso solo quiero una, una referencia ahora, le voy a dejar
a esto, esto ya veo que no hace falta tan alto, así que lo bajamos, esto del stock también lo quiere
súper bajo, pero me acabo de dar cuenta que no tengo el lift activado, y esto puede hacer un problema
con el stock, porque va a tardar un poco más, pero me da igual, va a tardar un poco más, pero me da igual,
001, esto no hace falta tanto, hemos quedado, 025,
esto tampoco hace falta tanto, 2, aquí vamos igual, no, lo voy a dejar en 3, lo voy a dejar en 3, porque igual ahora con el lift me doy cuenta que resulta que no valía eso,
y le vamos a poner, salir original en 0, cierre a fin de día, y esto lo voy a dejar que os siga entre 1 y 5,
ahora le voy a dejar al final, a ver qué tal, le voy a decir que termine en 10, cuando haga 10 consecutivas, que no mejore, que pare,
me da igual el valor, quiero encontrar una zona, esto lo hacemos mucho en las optimizaciones de búsqueda,
las iniciales, siempre ponemos esta variable en 3, cuando en 10 generaciones no mejora,
cuando hace días seguidas donde el mejor no cambia, entonces para, porque no hace falta llegar al final,
a mí no me interesa encontrar una zona donde vaya bien, y justamente de esa manera ya me vale,
estoy haciendo búsquedas podemos decir de zonas y demás, incluso si a veces se pueden aparecer zonas mejores,
mientras voy a ir bajando estos pdfs, de toda esta serie de open reach breakout ya si ya lo tengo,
playing the open reach breakout part 1, hostia toby cravel tío, toby cravel es un grande del open reach breakout,
hostia toby cravel es un grande del open reach breakout, es un auténtico especialista, pues muy buena esta serie que os voy a hacer,
si si si toby cravel, de hecho el libro de kauffman, ahora no recuerdo si este, pero tiene sistema de cravel,
me lo voy a llamar cravel, está muy bien esta, mira que bien, voy a bajar toda esta serie de cravel,
ah no, no estáis viendo, muy bien, si es que de verdad, open reach breakout parte 1, si ya lo he bajado,
si, este es el que acaba de bajar, parte 1, de príncipe lo contrase al expansio, esto es o no,
no pone el número 2, yo creo que sí, es de cravel también, vamos bajándolo todo, a ver hay que bajar, este es el 8, el 7,
parte 8, joder que salto me ha dado esto, está como desordenado no, hay parte 1, aquí parte 1, no, parte 1 ya lo he hecho no, joder,
si si parte 1 ya lo he hecho, mira me he empezado por arriba porque eso es un lío maco eh, si si toby cravel,
no se tío, no se tío, es eso, bueno pues tras este ejercicio de normalidad tan anormal, valga ver un poco de...
parece que va a tardar mucho pero ya veréis como acabará en cualquier momento, yo voy bajando aquí todos los open reach breakout que está esto un poco desordenado, no está fácil,
parte 6, la emisión está comenzando, como 05, no, 05 no, si, lo he puesto que pare en 10, Alberto, lo he puesto que pare en 10,
cuando 10, cuando no mejore en 10 para entonces, para que llegue a 50 como mucho para ahora, normal es que 50 o así pare,
si no oye nos quedamos aquí hasta las 12, 1 de la mañana y no pasa nada tampoco, pero total,
por miles de débiles, todavía aguantan todos ahí eh, están atentos, bueno vamos a ir a 05,
aquí todos ahí hasta el final aguantando, a ver cómo acaba esto,
como se tire alguien del barco, yo voy detrás como el capitán aquel del barco,
Ejercicio de normalidad tan anormal, sí, el concordia,
con palabras, aunque algo, el espagueti,
como se llamaba, escudentini, escadecidi era, no, escachenco era algo de escano,
esquetino, ves, ves, era algo de espagueti, ya me salía bien,
escatino era, era escaketo era, el escaketo era, no era el escaketo, era el escaqueco,
este ya lo he bajado, este ya lo he bajado, este ya lo he bajado,
pues no sé si están todos, eso es un poco raro eh, 8, pero 8 ya lo tengo,
es el 7-7, este también lo he bajado, este también lo he bajado,
por encima habéis visto, pero ahora vamos a profundizar en el barco,
en otro video ya hablaremos más profundamente del bar y del C-Bar,
este es el mismo que os he enseñado ahora, veremos el bar y demás,
para aquellos más avespados, parece que ya estaba calculado,
pero bueno, no he hablado mucho de él, porque quería hacer,
bueno, pues tras este ejercicio de normalidad tan anormal,
pero bueno, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está, ya está.
por encima habéis visto, pero ahora vamos a profundizar en el bar,
luego en otro video ya hablaremos más profundamente del bar y del C-Bar,
en el mismo Excel que os he enseñado ahora veremos, veremos el bar y demás,
para aquellos más avespados por ahí, me parece que ya estaba calculado,
No he hablado mucho de él porque quería hacer un vídeo específico y antes quería
explicaros qué es el bar, para aquellos que no hayáis oído nunca hablar
de esta medición de riesgo, el bar es value at risk, de acuerdo a sus cifras,
valor en riesgo, es una medida estadística, distintos algoritmos de
morning management que hay, no os voy a explicar todos aquí en las prácticas si
alguien tiene por si a por alguno, he usado muchos más, es un tema sobre el que
es un poco donde se acaba de hacer la unión de distinto y esto es un poco
donde se acaba de hacer la unión de distinto. Yo aquí voy repasando todos los artículos de estos con commodities que hablan de
la versión, que es una alternativa, un paper guapo, o que podría usarse en otros, en el final lo acabáis de ver calculado para el S&P
con un porcentaje de capital, vamos a, ahi lo tienes, bravo, justo acababa de decir que no para, espera que tengo aquí un paper abierto, sell short,
hombre, el word de Pevli, tenemos un articulito de Pevli aquí en stockcommodities, short entry, vamos a guardarlos aquí también,
intraday breakout strategy, perfecto, perfecto, pues nos viene bien, bajando, bajando también, todo eso he bajado ahí, bueno lo he llamado
Krabbel porque parecían de Krabbel todos, pero no, y ese es el último que me falta por mirar ya, ah, estos son cartas que pide la gente, bueno tampoco vamos a bajar las cartas
precision code, fashion art by the graphs, pues muy bien, ya está, pues nada, hemos bajado todo, a ver si todos los de Krabbel son buenos, montaremos un paper guapo ahí
para ver que hemos visto ahora aquí, ahora con el lift la cosa ha empeorado, ha ido a filtros más altos, es lo que me temía, y todo negativo, has visto el auto sample, todo negativo,
quería que vea cierto riesgo de ajuste, veo cierto riesgo de ajuste aquí, se ha ido ya a otro sitio ahora, bueno lo voy a dejar guardado con uno de estos, porque el que había antes seguramente estaba afectado por el lift, ese era el problema,
bueno así vamos a ver cuál equilibra, vamos a ver cuál equilibra en algo, no veo mucho equilibro aquí en ningún sitio yo, no sé por qué, ah bueno, está cogiendolo, el que más es 980, 980, aquí no, aquí parece, ah bueno, por expectancia no equilibra en ninguno, por expectancia no equilibra en ninguno, se hunde mucho el expectancia,
pues nada, lo vamos a dejar aquí, queremos saber qué tal, habría que hacerla así con el lift por el otro lado, ya digo, este era un poco para que lo vieras un poco funcionar y sin más, no queríamos tampoco, pero así ya te digo, no, no está saliendo nada, no es como de grada al final,
que ver puede ser circunstancial, eso es lo que siempre hay que mirarlo, pero estamos de acuerdo que la entrada no es una buena señal, entonces hay que tomarse, tomar nuestras precauciones,
05, no, 05 no, así que nada más, lo vamos a dejar por hoy aquí, proceso la clase ahora cuando acabo, yo os he dejado ahí los tres documentitos,
la emisión está comenzando, miraremos de traducir todo esto que he encontrado en esto con commodities que ya tenía pensado mirarlo, mirarlo hoy y ver a ver qué nos da, porque esa es mi idea, siempre la otra vez me lo miré, a ver qué nos puede ir dando,
que nos podemos ir sacando y también poder daros un poquito de material, nada más nos vemos el viernes, el lunes que viene, si, el lunes que viene nos vemos, quedaran dos días para que cumpla 51 años,
y por lo tanto el lunes que viene tomo clase, no sé si tomo el otro, pero el que viene el cuatro tenemos clase, acabaremos este y espero poder acabar este, poder hacer alguna versión de, no sé si este exactamente porque la entrada está muy limitada,
pero sí que trataremos, trataremos de que este sea algo aprovechable y en todo caso presentaremos algún range breakout mientras diga aprovechable, de acuerdo, es decir, si no es este porque este es el final, hemos desarrollado la de la primera hora,
que así como está hay activos donde funciona cien por cien, pero no necesita activos muy tendenciales y es lo que digo el DAX, bueno ya lo estáis viendo aquí, es lo que os decía, esta pauta tiene movimiento y es complicado todo un día de movimiento,
claro que encontraremos alguno, pero es muy complicado, el DAX tiene a morirse pasada la, mira ese es un día fantástico y fijaros aquí y se acabó, 12, y sí que luego sigue tirando, pues seguramente era un día que Wall Street subió lo que no estaba escrito y al final lo va siguiendo,
pero es raro tener una tendencia muy limpia, es muy tendiente a erratizar en esas horas post 11, 12 hasta que no llegan las noticias y ahí las noticias ya sabéis que es la locura, entonces es un activo típico para operarlo de entrada y luego es un caso mejor tratar de montar algo con las noticias,
aprovechar ahí y subirse las noticias, montar un range breakout en las noticias para seguir hasta la hora de apretar Wall Street y ahí salirse, adiós, adiós muy buenas a las 5 y media, es quizá lo que yo probaría, primera hora, 10 y luego quizá la hora de las noticias un poco antes mirar buscar una rotura y fuera,
seguimos el próximo día, buen año el 73, muy buena cosecha, de marzo el 73, hasta el lunes que viene, chao.